So, da bin ich.
Ach ja.
Können wir uns nachher angucken.
Ja Leute, es geht.
Wann war das da hinten jetzt gewesen?
Yo, du warst noch nicht pennen?
Oh, der Tee schmeckt heute irgendwie komisch.
Das, das.
Abgelaufen oder was?
Schwer zu definieren, nach was das schmeckt.
Ich meine, es sollte eigentlich nach Kamillentee schmecken.
Aber es schmeckt nach Kamillentee mit irgendwas anderem drin.
Aber mit irgendwas, was da nicht reingehört.
Keine Ahnung.
Bisschen, es schmeckt.
Leute, ich weiß wie es schmeckt.
Das kann ich nicht trinken.
Das schmeckt wie Kamillentee, aber mit Schwimmbadwasser gemacht.
Also nicht nach Chlor oder so.
Aber es schmeckt irgendwie nach dreckigem Schwimmbadwasser.
Keine Ahnung.
Alles zu der Vergangenheit war es über Crowds und Reggae-Skills.
Also über Crowds.
Nee, nach Chlor nicht.
Schon mal kritische Daten in einen öffentlich lesbaren S3-Bucket gelockt.
Nee.
Also, zumindest noch nicht, dass ich das wüsste, ja.
Also, über Crowdstrike habe ich mich schon ein paar Mal ausgelassen.
Gut, ich meine, ich war jetzt fast eine Woche nicht on.
Also, da ist ja einiges Neues rausgekommen.
Da wusste man noch nicht, dass es sich wohl um einen Regex handelte.
Man dachte vor einer Woche ja noch.
Also, ganz am Anfang dachte man, es war irgendwie eine Nullpoint.
Eine Nullpoint-Exception, wo einfach einer Shit programmiert hat.
Dann kam raus, eigentlich war das irgendein Typ, der keine Ahnung hatte, der das verbreitet hat.
Und es ist doch komplizierter.
Und dann habe ich aufgehört, das Ganze zu verfolgen.
Und mittlerweile ist das das mit dem...
Ja, ich weiß, wir müssen den Rest machen.
Mittlerweile ist das das mit dem Regex.
Das habe ich mir ehrlich gesagt noch gar nicht so sehr im Detail angeguckt.
Aber wahrscheinlich ist es jetzt auch nicht so wild, oder?
Ob, was es jetzt genau gewesen ist.
Ja.
Das große Problem war ja, erstens, dass es nicht getestet ist.
Zumindest sieht das ein richtig Ausbreter im Vorfeld.
Ja.
Und dass das irgendwas ist, was quasi so on the fly live updated.
Und in der Rollout-Strategie auch einfach alles auf einmal.
Da gab es ja so ein paar Dinger, wo man sich fragt, ey, das hätte man vermeiden können.
Ob das jetzt wirklich...
Also, was es da jetzt genau gewesen ist, das habe ich mir nicht angeguckt.
Also, ja, ich habe ein paar O'Reilly Bücher.
Aber die sind über 10 Jahre alt.
Und mittlerweile kaufe ich mir eigentlich gar keine Bücher mehr.
Und auch keine Bücher, das schließt für mich auch E-Books und sowas mit ein.
Für Technik-Sachen.
Ich glaube, das Letzte, was ich mir gekauft habe...
Ich kann jetzt nicht sagen, vielleicht gab es das ein oder andere.
Das Letzte, was ich mir gekauft habe, war...
Also, das zählt nicht wirklich als Buch.
Das Buch war, glaube ich, eine Udemy-Einführung zu...
Weiß gar nicht mehr.
Irgendeinen Udemy-Kurs habe ich mir mal gekauft vor 3-4 Jahren.
Das zählt ja quasi auch so ein bisschen, nennen wir es mal, als Paid-Content in Richtung Buch.
Aber...
Ah gut, das ist wahrscheinlich ewig lang, oder?
Ja, nein, das können wir...
Das lesen wir uns jetzt nicht durch.
Lohnt sich das in Ruhe mal irgendwann durchzulesen?
Oder ist das im Prinzip viel Blabla um kleinen Kram?
Weil das machen die ja auch gerne, mit solchen Dokumenten.
Die schwätzen dann drei Seiten und ein Satz ist wichtig, so.
Ja, ich glaube, das war das Letzte.
Und so wirklich echte Bücher...
Kann ich mich nicht daran erinnern, was das Letzte war, was ich mir gekauft habe.
Also, ich kann nicht sagen, was das dickste Buch war, was ich mir je gekauft habe.
Fachliteraturmäßig, und das steht hier hinten noch.
Oder...
Rede mir nicht das.
Das stand hier hinten.
Ja, das steht immer noch da.
Das...
Das sehe ich jetzt aber von hier nicht richtig.
Das war eine Einführung.
Oder eine...
Keine Einführung, das war ein...
Ey, kein C++-Buch.
Das war ein WPF-Buch.
Das habe ich mir aber...
Ihr könnt euch vorstellen, wie alt das schon ist.
Hier, WPF.
Das war so ein Ding, quasi in der Richtung.
So ein super, super fettes Buch.
Irgendwie 1800 Seiten.
Also so mega fett.
Also fetter als Herr der Ringe.
Buch über WPF.
Ich habe es nie gelesen.
Ich dachte damals, WPF ist die Zukunft, was Desktop-Anwendungen in C-Sharp angeht.
Man könnte natürlich irgendwo sagen, ja, ist es auch gewesen.
Aber WPF fuckt mich so ab.
Allein schon, wenn ich an irgendwelche XML-GUI-Deklarations gedönst...
Da kriege ich...
Nee, nee, nee.
Mit WPF habe ich mich auseinandergesetzt und habe festgestellt...
WPF geht mir auf den Sack.
Ich meine, dass die es geschafft haben, mit UWP den schlechtesten Part von WPF plus die guten Sachen zu entfernen und zwei schlechte Sachen zusammen...
Ist ja nochmal das Nächste.
Aber UWP juckt glücklicherweise kaum noch jemand.
Ich mache mal Package-Updates.
Oh, hier.
Da wird irgendwas replaced.
Ruby wird replaced.
Ruby.
Ich bestätige das einfach mal.
Warum haben die das...
Ah, guck mal, die haben die...
Die Ruby-Sachen aus Base nach Extra verschoben.
Wahrscheinlich, weil sich keiner mal Bock hat, um Ruby-Sachen zu kümmern.
Dü-dü-dü-dü-dü-dü-dü-dü-dü-dü-dü.
Andere Musik.
War eigentlich nur fürs Intro.
Oh, guck mal.
JetBrains hat geupdatet.
Aber wie?
Hast du mitbekommen, dass der Anzeigen-Hauptmeister während der Fahrstunde...
An der Ampel stand den Motor aus...
...gemacht hat und eine Ordnungswidrigkeit fotografiert hat?
Nö.
Aber das passt zum Anzeigen-Hauptmeister.
Oder hat er sich dann selbst fotografiert, weil er da zu lang stand?
Aber das muss man doch sagen.
Der hat sich ja immerhin selbst gemeldet bei der Polizei.
Das ist ja ein Mensch von Konsequenz.
So.
Jetzt gibt's erstmal...
Das braucht mehr CPU-Last und mehr Speicher als jedes OS-Update.
Vier Packages Jetbrain-Dinge updaten.
Passt mal auf hier.
Das hier oben ist meine CPU.
Auslastung.
Die wird jetzt einfach mal auf nahezu 100% gehen, wenn das Jetbrains-Zeug updatet.
Ja, guckt's euch an.
Ich bin mir nicht so sicher, warum das Updaten so wahnsinnig CPU-intensiv ist von diesem Shit.
Keine Ahnung, was die da treiben.
Okay, das Unpacking vielleicht.
Ja, aber guck mal.
Ich sag hier.
Nahezu 100% CPU-Auslastung, wenn man vier IDEs updatet.
Mal gucken, was zuerst fertig ist.
Rust Rover.
Blazingly Fast.
Sogar die IDE updatet als erstes.
Bitcoin-Mining.
Ja, genau.
Na, Bitcoin-Mining ist ja out.
Was machen eigentlich, wo ich gerade dabei bin?
Zack, Leute.
Lasst mich mal kurz an meinen Stonks gucken, weil die sind da ziemlich runtergegangen in den letzten zwei Wochen.
Wie war es diese Woche so?
Ja, die sind wieder ein bisschen hochgegangen.
Die Stonks sind wieder back.
Nein, nicht ganz.
Nicht ganz, aber die sind wieder ein bisschen...
Aber trotzdem immer noch.
Das ist so krass, ne?
Ich hab genau den richtigen Zeitpunkt erwischt.
Ich hab einen richtig großen...
Also, ich hab auch nichts Tolles, ne?
Ich hab einen World-ETF.
Und ich hab da, als die ganze Geschichte mit der Ukraine angefangen hat
und das so tief runtergefallen ist,
hab ich quasi fast die gesamte Kohle von meinem YouTube-Business-Konto genommen,
weil das liegt da eh...
Das ist halt einfach bescheuert, das da rumliegen zu lassen.
Hab das überwiesen und hab World-ETF gekauft.
Und seitdem ist der trotz diesem kleinen Einbruch jetzt die letzten zwei Wochen,
ist der immer noch...
Ist der immer noch plus 44%.
Da kann man sich nicht beschweren.
Läuft bei dir ein Hauptsystem Windows oder Linux?
Äh, Windows.
Das hier ist das Hauptsystem.
Es hätte auch nach hinten losgehen können, ja?
Aber ich hab mir gedacht,
der Display bleibt bestimmt nicht immer so.
Und zack.
Wenn es so weitergeht, fette Stonks.
Also, ich hab Windows hier als Hauptbetriebssystem
und hier Linux in der VM.
Machen wir hier nochmal Updates.
Oh, Jetbrains.
Jetbrains ist fertig.
Scalable.
Ich hab jetzt auf Reddit gelesen, dass Trade Republic,
obwohl es da immer so als Geheimtipp empfohlen wurde,
nicht mehr so beliebt ist.
Ich hab's aber nicht verstanden, warum.
Aber das Finanzen-Subreddit ändert da eh öfters mal die Meinung.
Linux läuft über die VM, ja.
Guck hier.
Warte mal.
Das ist eigentlich nur VMware Workstation im Fullscreen.
Aber, wenn man das gescheit macht,
du bist nicht der Erste,
der dir das verwirrt,
weil, man sieht das nicht.
Ja?
Die Frage kommt öfters.
Und zwar, was ich gemacht hab, ist,
ich benutze mehrere Windows-Desktops.
Sowas ist mittlerweile in Windows tatsächlich eingebaut.
Seit Windows 10, glaube ich, ist das der Fall.
Gibt es mehrere Desktops.
Leider hat Microsoft die Desktop-Switch-Animation entfernt
zwischen Windows 10 und Windows 11.
Unter Windows 11, unter Windows 10 hat man noch erkannt,
wenn der Desktop geswitcht wird.
So, und wenn man die passenden Shortcuts verwendet,
dann funktioniert das wunderbar.
Man kann nämlich hier mit der Tastatur,
kann man quasi hier den Fokus aus der VM rausnehmen
und mehr oder weniger mit fast den gleichen Tasten
und Windows-Taste links und rechts,
also Windows-Taste und Windows-Control und Pfeiltasten,
kann man zwischen den Windows-Desktops switchen.
Das heißt, im Endeffekt ist es ziemlich gut integriert.
Ich kann jetzt hier rüber switchen und zurück
und bin wieder drinnen.
Und es sieht aus,
als wären es eigentlich so quasi zwei unterschiedliche PC-Inputs,
die ich hier irgendwie mit einer Capture-Card umschalten würde oder so.
Aber dafür ist es halt auch viel zu schnell.
Und die ich umschalten würde in OBS oder so was,
ist es aber nicht.
Das switcht.
Das ist im Prinzip Windows-Windows-Desktops.
Guck, erster Desktop, zweiter Desktop, dritter Desktop.
So, jetzt haben wir mal Betriebssystem-Updates gemacht.
Reboot.
Ja.
Habt ihr die Geschichte mit Manifest V3 mitbekommen,
dass Google das jetzt ernst meint?
Ah, heiße News.
Oh.
Haben wir auch was drüber geschrieben.
Was macht der neue PC mit Sunlight?
Das gefällt mir nicht.
Das gibt Probleme mit dem Sound.
Man merkt, dass das nicht als Remote-Desktop-Lösung gedacht ist,
sondern hauptsächlich für Games.
Es gibt Probleme mit dem Sound.
Den Rest habe ich schon wieder vergessen.
Was es für Soundprobleme gibt, weiß ich gerade nicht.
Das ist das erste, was mir einfällt.
Das war jetzt nicht so geil.
Ja.
Also, Manifest V3 am Start und man bekommt jetzt, genau,
man bekommt jetzt Meldung.
Ich habe es noch nicht bekommen, aber ich glaube,
ich habe noch nicht die allerneueste Chrome-Version, vermutlich.
Wo kann man hier, wo kann man hier Updates, Updates Tools?
Wo kann man den checken lassen?
Hilfe?
Ob es neue Updates gibt?
Keine Ahnung.
Scheint zu komplex zu sein.
Hilfe?
Über Chrome?
Ist auf dem neuesten Stand.
Okay.
Also ich, ich kriege die Meldung noch nicht.
Gucken wir mal hier.
Extensions.
Ja, also ich, ich kriege die Meldung noch nicht.
Oder muss man in den Webstore?
Ah ja, genau.
Hier.
Diese Erweiterung wird möglicherweise bald nicht mehr unterstützt,
da sie nicht den Best Practices für Chrome-Erweiterung entspricht.
Das ist natürlich auch eine sehr schöne Umschreibung, ne?
Dass sie nicht den Best Practices.
Es ist jetzt nicht, als dass die gegen irgendwelche Best Practices
in Form von wie man eine Anwendung entwickelt.
Die, die, die entspricht nicht dem neuesten Shit,
den sich Google ausgedacht hat,
um mehr Geld zu machen.
Also, insofern ist das, naja, also die, die Beschreibung ist jetzt nicht ganz falsch,
aber die trifft es nicht so wirklich, ja?
So, zumindest wenn das der Fall sein sollte,
sobald in Chrome, also Chromium hat das Problem gar nicht.
Vermutlich.
Ich, ich vermute mal, Chromium hat das Problem gar nicht.
Wenn.
Chrome, Chromium und so.
Wenn die Browser diese Probleme bekommen sollten,
ja, also sollte das wirklich der Fall sein,
dass das abgeschaltet wird,
dann ist es halt einfach wieder Firefox.
Fertig.
Gibt es die Blockliste von uBlock in,
das sind zwei komplett unterschiedliche paar Software.
Die machen auch komplett unterschiedliche Sachen.
Also uBlock hat nicht einfach nur eine Blocklist,
DNS-Namen blocken, wie das, wie das Pi-Hole macht,
sondern nachdem das ein Browser-Plugin ist,
macht uBlock viel mehr.
uBlock ändert den Content der Seite.
Das heißt, du kannst nur einen Bruchteil,
einen ganz kleinen Bruchteil von dem, was uBlock macht, in Pi-Hole machen
und Pi-Hole blockt heutzutage so gut wie keine Werbung mehr.
Weil DNS-Blocking halt eben nicht ausreicht.
Du brauchst ein Browser-Plugin, was wirklich den Content der Seite
anfassen kann, beziehungsweise eingreifen kann,
wie die Seite gerendert wird.
Also das wird dir nichts bringen.
Also da gibt es nichts, außer ein paar DNS-Namen zu importieren.
Das meiste, was uBlock macht, ist nicht möglich mit dem, was Pi-Hole macht.
Ja.
Und wisst ihr, was auch witzig ist?
Im gleichen Atemzug hat Google,
ich weiß nicht, ob ihr das mitbekommen habt,
wir gucken uns das gleich mal in der VM an.
So, eh starten.
So, wir gucken uns das gleich mal in der VM an.
Also, zum gleichen Zeitpunkt hat natürlich Google,
passenderweise, weil Google ja so ein netter Laden ist,
hat Google die Firefox,
den Firefox-Deal gekündigt.
Habe ich gelesen.
Warum findet man das nicht?
Findet man das hier in News nicht?
Also ich habe in News gelesen, dass Google den Firefox-Deal gekündigt hat.
Also es war ja so, Firefox, also Mozilla,
also der Laden hinter Firefox,
macht glaube ich 85% ihres Geldes über Google-Werbung.
Also über das, dass die Leute zu Google weiterleiten.
Und wenn das halt wegfällt,
ist es halt ein ziemlich großer Batzen der Kohle von Firefox.
Ich muss euch aber ehrlich sagen,
ich finde das gar nicht so schlimm, wie es sich anhört,
weil ich habe eh keine Ahnung, was Mozilla in den letzten Jahren so treibt.
Die könnten sich einfach mal auf ihren Browser fokussieren,
und zwar auf das, was Firefox eigentlich ursprünglich mal gewesen ist.
Ein Browser für technikinteressierte Leute,
wo du viel mitmachen kannst,
wo du auch viel customizen kannst
und wo du auch viel generell mitmachen kannst,
was mit anderen Browsern eben nicht geht.
Was ist mit Opera?
Was soll mit Opera?
Das gibt es immer noch.
Ich glaube, Opera möchte das weiter unterstützen.
Aber ganz ehrlich, Opera ist halt so ein China-Chinesen-Ding.
Da hätte ich prinzipiell schon keinen Bock drauf.
Kann man nicht einfach einen Proxy mit SSL nehmen und ihnen dann sagen,
ja doch, das kannst du schon, wenn du weißt, was du machen musst?
Ja, ja.
Also in der Theorie her geht das sicherlich.
Auf der anderen Seite,
ein Adblocker macht auch Sachen,
die du nicht mitmachen kannst.
Also ich würde sagen,
ich habe mich noch nie mit Adblocker-Entwicklung beschäftigt.
Ich würde sagen,
ein Adblocker kann prinzipiell drei verschiedene Stufen,
kann auch sein, dass das mehr ist oder weniger,
so wie ich mir das vorstelle,
ein Adblocker hat prinzipiell drei verschiedene Stufen,
wie er Ads blocken kann.
Das erste ist,
es werden einfach URLs geblockt.
Also das ist ein bisschen sowas,
was Pi-Hole auch macht,
so nach dem Motto,
das ist eine bekannte Werbe-URL,
die blocken wir einfach.
Das nächste ist,
Pi-Hole kann die Webseiten untersuchen nach,
sagen wir mal,
irgendwelchen iFrame-Includes von Seiten
oder nach Elementen,
die aussehen, als wären sie Werbung.
Adblock passt dann quasi das HTML-Dokument
und guckt,
okay, das sieht so aus,
wie Werbung,
Werbebild und das können wir dann entfernen.
So und das dritte ist,
dass das wirklich in die Logik eingreift für Webseiten.
Also sprich,
dass das zum Beispiel auf Google sieht,
aha, der Player startet jetzt mit dem Video,
daraufhin wird quasi was geladen
und dann sehen die quasi in irgendeinem Aufruf in JavaScript,
aha, das ist jetzt ein Werbevideo.
Also die müssen quasi in die JavaScript-Runtime eingreifen
für die Webseite,
um was blocken zu können.
Das wird natürlich immer schwieriger gemacht.
Das ist ja auch gerade so das Wettrennen
zwischen Werbung auf Google geblockt oder nicht geblockt,
Werbung auf YouTube geblockt oder nicht geblockt.
So und das sind so Sachen,
das kannst du nur mit einem Browser-Plugin machen,
weil Pi-Hole kann DNS-Namen blocken,
mehr nicht.
Es hat keinerlei Zugriff auf den Seiteninhalt.
Ein Proxy, der Man-in-the-Middle-SSL macht,
der könnte eventuell die Webseite,
das HTML der Webseite parsen
und dort Werbung rausschmeißen.
Was der nicht kann,
ist in deinem JavaScript rumfuhrwerken,
weil das ja erst kleinseitig im Browser läuft.
Kleinseitig.
Das musst du mit einem Browser-Plugin machen.
Also du kommst im Prinzip an einem Browser-Plugin
oder an einem Custom-Browser,
wo das schon integriert ist,
kommst du nicht vorbei,
wenn du einen ordentlichen Werbeblocker haben willst.
Das funktioniert nicht.
Pi-Hole habe ich, ehrlich gesagt,
den Hype noch nie großartig drum verstanden.
Bei mir hat das nie zufriedenstellend funktioniert,
was aber auch logisch ist,
was bei keinem zufriedenstellend je funktioniert hat,
weil das eben nichts mehr machen kann,
als aus DNS-Namen blocken.
Pi-Hole hat am Anfang mal ganz gut funktioniert
für diese ganz klassischen Ad-Netzwerke.
Zum Beispiel, du bist auf irgendeine News-Seite gegangen
und die Hälfte der Seite war Telekom-Werbung
mit irgendeinem Shit und sowas.
Das wurde über externe Ad-Netzwerke,
Ad-Netzwerke nachgeladen.
Dafür hat Pi-Hole funktioniert,
hat aber auch dafür gesorgt,
dass die Seiten beim Laden manchmal hingen
und solche Geschichten.
Also, war alles nicht schön.
Bei mir hat Pi-Hole nie zufriedenstellend funktioniert.
Ich behaupte,
das hat bei keinem bisher je richtig gut
zufriedenstellend funktioniert,
außer für die most basic Sachen schlechthin.
Aber mittlerweile auch nicht mehr gut.
Das heißt, du kommst um Ad-Blocker nicht drum herum.
Was scheiße ist für Smartphones,
je nachdem, was du machen willst,
weil sobald du ein Smartphone hast,
wo du die Anwendung nicht mehr im Browser benutzt,
sondern über eine extra App,
hast du ja gar nicht mehr so wirklich Einfluss drauf,
was du da für Plugins und Zusatzfunktionen installierst.
Wenn du Glück hast,
hast du noch ein halbwegs offenes Smartphone
wie ein Android,
wo du selbst Sachen nachladen kannst.
Da kannst du dir zum Beispiel
eine alternative YouTube-App installieren,
die einen Ad-Blocker drin hat.
So, was gibt es denn da?
Newpipe und YouTube Vanced und so Zeug gab es da früher.
Wenn du ein iOS-Gerät hast,
hast du ziemlich die Arschkarre.
Da gibt es mittlerweile ein paar Möglichkeiten,
aber unter iOS ist es abfuck.
Und das ist einzig und allein,
warum?
Weil man Geld verdienen will.
Logisch, was sonst?
Maximiert Geld verdienen will.
Also unter iOS hast du ziemlich gelitten,
wenn du nicht die offizielle YouTube-App verwenden willst.
Also gelitten nicht unbedingt,
aber du hast einen deutlich höheren Aufwand.
Deswegen habe ich die andere Art des Ad-Blockers gewählt.
Ich kaufe mir meine YouTube-Abos über Indien.
Was angeblich nicht mehr geht.
Und ich bin mal gespannt,
wenn ich mein nächstes YouTube-Premium renewen muss,
ob ich dann auch über Indien bezahlen kann.
Chatge, macht irgendjemand von euch
über YouTube-Premium über Indien?
Das kostet dann irgendwie 280 indische Rupien oder sowas.
Das sind dann irgendwie 2,50 Euro oder sowas.
Versus glaube ich 14,99 in Deutschland.
Wie viel kostet es in der Ukraine?
Also Indien hat bei mir funktioniert.
Ich musste ein indisches Payment-Profil bei Google anlegen.
Dann hat es funktioniert.
2,50 Euro.
Okay.
Ja, dann funktioniert das anscheinend immer noch.
Ich bin mal gespannt, wenn ich das wieder...
Wurde dein Abo nicht gecancelt, wenn du...
Wurde das?
Nee, oder?
Es kann nicht gecancelt worden sein.
Es kann sein, dass es mal gecancelt wurde,
aber ich habe YouTube-Premium immer noch am Laufen.
Und es wird hier laufend Werbung.
Lass mich mal kurz gucken.
Your YouTube...
Your YouTube Pre...
Nein, ich kann nicht mehr lesen.
Your Premium Benefits habe ich, wenn ich in mein Profil gehe.
Und wenn ich Your Premium Benefits habe, gehe ich...
Oder wollen die mir das verkaufen an der Stelle nur?
Nee.
Mein Abo würde mit hin, dass ich nicht irgendwo...
Naja, ich habe das immer über Indien, über ein indisches...
Ich habe ja nicht mal VPN benutzt.
Ich habe kein indisches VPN benutzt.
Ich habe mir eine indische VM gemietet bei DigitalOcean.
Die haben nämlich ein...
Rechenzentrum in Bangalore.
Geiler Name, oder?
Und das ist in Indien.
Da hast du eine indische IP.
Und darüber habe ich mich getunnelt mit SSH.
Ich habe SSH...
Also, ihr wisst ja, ich mag keine VPN-Anbieter.
Und wenn ich irgendwas in der Richtung brauche, mache ich das selbst.
Oder...
Ja, manchmal mache ich auch mit VPN-Anbieter.
Aber in der Regel mache ich das so.
Es ist super easy, einen Browser zu tunneln.
Einen Browser zu tunneln über eine VM.
Ihr mietet euch eine VM.
Also, wenn man ein bisschen Ahnung von Linux hat.
Ihr mietet euch die Linux-VM.
Dann verbindet ihr euch per SSH drauf.
SSH minus...
N minus...
P...
Ach, ich weiß es aus dem Kopf nicht genau.
Zumindest macht ihr einen SOX-Proxy auf.
Und dann stellt ihr euren lokalen Browser auf diesen Proxy um.
Und schon habt ihr quasi einen...
LightVPN.
Und kommt in Indien raus.
Kann jeder VMware Workstation benutzen?
Mittlerweile angeblich schon.
Ich glaube, mittlerweile ist VMware Workstation sogar free.
Wenn ich das richtig in Erinnerung habe.
Ich habe es gekauft.
Ich habe es noch gekauft.
Aber ich bilde mir ein, mittlerweile...
Ist das kostenlos.
Gucken wir mal.
Ja, die VMware-Seite ist halt wieder pepega.
Man findet wieder nichts.
Seht ihr es irgendwo?
VMware Workstation, da ist es doch.
Lol.
Oh ja, du musst dir...
Okay, du musst dir einen Broadcom-Account machen.
Wenn man das...
Na ja, gut.
Kommt man halt nicht drum herum.
Ja.
Also, du kannst jetzt mittlerweile anscheinend kostenlos runter landen.
Früher gab es nur den VMware Player, der kostenlos war.
Aber mittlerweile anscheinend komplette VMware Workstation.
Also, wie gesagt, ich habe es noch gekauft.
Für ein Apfel und ein Ei.
Bei einem fragwürdigen Keystore.
Damals.
Aber anscheinend ist es mittlerweile kostenlos für alle.
Also, ich habe keine indische Kreditkarte.
Ich bezahle über PayPal.
Aber ich habe ein indisches Payment-Profil angelegt damals.
Für YouTube.
Ich kann euch aus dem Kopf nicht mehr genau sagen, wie das ging.
Ich weiß nur, dass ich normal nicht bezahlen konnte.
Dass ich ein indisches Payment-Profil gebraucht habe.
Ich habe mich über meine DigitalOcean-VM in Bangalore eingeloggt.
Und dann ging das.
Bist du unzufrieden mit Firefox?
Nö.
Das einzige, womit ich unzufrieden bin, was Firefox angeht, ist.
Und das kann kein Firefox-Fork oder irgendwas der Welt höchstwahrscheinlich ändern.
Ist der Fokus von Mozilla.
Ich finde, die haben es die letzten...
Ach ja, da war ich ja gerade am erzählen.
Genau.
Ich finde, die haben es die letzten Jahre etwas zu sehr davon wegbewegt.
Einen Browser zu liefern, der für Technikinteressierte ist.
Mit dem du einfach...
Firefox war für mich ursprünglich der Browserschlechter.
Ich habe nur Firefox verwendet.
Gerade die Kombination früher.
Die Möglichkeit zu customizen.
Ich meine jetzt nicht die Optik.
An Plugins.
Firefox-Plugins konnten bzw. können so viel im Browser ändern, wie bei keinem anderen Browser.
Erinnert sich noch einer an das alte...
Nicht uBlock.
An das alte NoScript.
Kennt noch jemand NoScript?
Das alte NoScript?
Kennt das noch jemand?
Das gibt es in der heutigen Form nicht mehr bzw. verwendet keinem.
Das alte NoScript.
Das war das Beste überhaupt.
Damit konntest du so krass customizen, was eine Webseite darf.
Wie nie wieder danach.
Also uBlock macht es deutlich einfacher als NoScript.
NoScript musstest du wirklich jede Seite...
Die du besucht hast zum ersten Mal.
U-Matrix versucht etwas ähnliches.
Aber NoScript, gerade das alte NoScript, was jetzt auch nicht mehr funktioniert.
Das war wirklich next level.
Du konntest wirklich jeden Scheiß an der Webseite einstellen, was sie durfte.
Was natürlich auch dazu geführt hat, dass sobald du NoScript installiert hast und auf die Webseite gegangen bist, die Webseite erstmal nicht funktioniert hat.
Das gibt es nicht mehr, das alte NoScript.
Nein, das gibt es nicht mehr.
NoScript gibt es noch.
Aber es gibt nicht mehr das alte NoScript.
Das alte NoScript wurde quasi unbrauchbar gemacht, als Firefox ihre Plugin APIs geändert hat.
Zu, boah frag mich nicht, vor 4-5 Jahren oder so.
Ja und ich finde, da hat sich Mozilla ein bisschen von weg bewegt, eben so einen Hackerman Browser zu liefern.
So einen Browser, der einfach richtig nice war für technikinteressierte Leute.
Mozilla hat sich um allen möglichen Krempel gekümmert.
Um VPNs.
Um Bookmark Services.
Um Browser für Noobs.
Um neue Mobile Browser.
Um alles mögliche.
Um, by the way, wisst ihr Chat, um was sich Mozilla noch gekümmert hat?
Krustentiere werden das mögen.
Ich finde Pocket an sich gar nicht schlecht.
Fragt man sich, warum sowas unbedingt von Mozilla gemacht werden muss.
Ich benutze Pocket auch manchmal.
Rust.
Also ich würde sagen, wenn sich Mozilla auf wirklich Firefox...
Und Rust fokussiert.
Das wäre wahrscheinlich für alle Beteiligten das Beste.
Meinetwegen, meinetwegen können sie Thunderbird auch noch ab und zu updaten.
Wobei ich, für meinen Geschmack, ich bräuchte Thunderbird gar nicht.
Ich benutze das, ja, ich habe das immer noch, immer noch installiert.
Ich benutze das immer noch für meine, für meine Mail-Accounts.
Aber ich bräuchte es nicht.
Also ich könnte auch irgendwas anderes verwenden und ich bräuchte, wenn man es mal ganz genau nimmt, eigentlich bräuchte ich überhaupt kein E-Mail-Programm mehr.
Ich könnte mich einfach auch in das Web-Interface vom jeweiligen Anbieter einloggen.
Das wäre an sich überhaupt gar kein Problem.
Und der Grund, warum ich Firefox verwende, ist eigentlich historisch.
Weil ich habe Firefox schon seit 20 Jahren.
Wahrscheinlich länger.
Länger.
Seit wann gibt es, äh, nicht Firefox, sorry, Thunderbird meine ich.
Thunderbird.
Seit wann gibt es Thunderbird?
Ich hatte Outlook Express in Windows 98 und so.
Und danach hatte ich gleich Thunderbird.
Ja, Version, Version.
Wann kam das erste raus?
Äh.
Wird das nicht hier irgendwo?
Ja, 2003, ja.
Ja, so in dem Dreh, so in dem Dreh.
Ja, also ich habe das, ich habe das schon ziemlich von Anfang an verwendet.
Guck mal hier, Programmiersprachen, C, C++, JavaScript und Rust.
Deswegen ist es auch so blazingly fast.
Ja, also ganz ehrlich, Thunderbird ist alles andere als blazingly fast.
Ja.
Ich hatte noch, ich hatte noch unter Windows 98 und Windows 2000 und sowas, hatte ich noch Outlook Express.
Falls diesen Krempel noch irgendjemand kennt von Microsoft.
Und danach hatte ich Thunderbird.
Und deswegen habe ich heute auch noch Thunderbird, weil ich habe alle meine E-Mail-Accounts noch.
Also als Offline.
Damals hat man ja noch den M-Box abgerufen, also über POP3.
Und ich habe die, ich habe alle E-Mails noch der letzten 20 Jahre.
Und die habe ich halt in diesem, in diesem Thunderbird-Format.
Und das wurde immer mit migrated.
Ich habe, ich habe da noch, ich habe da Dinger drinne.
Ich habe noch, in Thunderbird habe ich noch Dinger stehen von, wo ich Zivildienst gemacht habe.
Meine, meine Ausbildungsbewerbung und so.
Da ist ur, ur, uraltes Zeug drinne.
Da sind bestimmt auch die übelsten Cringe-Messages drinne, die ich geschrieben habe.
Aber in Thunderbird ist quasi so meine komplette E-Mail-History seit 20 Jahren drinne.
Und das ist eigentlich der hauptsächliche Grund.
Jetzt nicht, dass ihr denkt, dass es nur da drinne ist, ja.
Aber benutzbar ist es nur da drinne.
Also mein, wenn mein Rechner verreckt oder so, da müsste ich halt den kompletten Thunderbird-Ordner restoren.
Und dann Thunderbird installieren und sagen, hier, lest den Ordner ein.
Aber deswegen habe ich noch Thunderbird.
Für neue Mails bräuchte ich es eigentlich nicht.
Weil der Web-Client bei allen halbwegs modernen E-Mail-Anbietern ist okay.
Ob ich jetzt Google Mail verwende im Browser, Google Mail über Thunderbird.
Was übrigens gar nicht mehr so einfach ist, Google Mail über Thunderbird zu verwenden.
Das musst du erst dreimal freischalten, dass es funktioniert.
Oder Zeug. Das ist eigentlich egal.
Also für neue Sachen bräuchte ich auf jeden Fall kein Thunderbird mehr.
Aber ich habe es noch und ich werde es wahrscheinlich auch für immer behalten.
Wegen E-Mail-History.
Ja.
Sieht's aus.
Ja, das war mein Aufhänger, warum ich da drüber geredet habe.
Weil ich gesagt habe, dass ich Firefox vielleicht, beziehungsweise Mozilla,
vielleicht jetzt ein bisschen aufs Wesentliche wieder konzentrieren kann.
Ach ja, und für die Frage, was das hier für eine Linux ist,
habe ich heute noch gar nicht erwähnt, Leute.
Arch, by the way, natürlich.
Was sonst?
I use Arch.
Um genau zu sein, ist es ein Arch.
Genau zu sein, ist es ein Arch Linux mit I3WM.
Noch mit X.
Irgendwo steht das hier auch.
Hier.
I3WM auf X-Basis oder X-Org-Basis.
Das liegt aber daran, nicht, dass ich unbedingt X verwenden will,
sondern weil X das Einzige ist, was gescheit funktioniert.
Any Wayland-Enjoyers.
X ist das Einzige, was gescheit funktioniert.
Wir haben es hier öfters ausprobiert mit Wayland.
Hat immer irgendwelche Abfuck-Probleme gehabt.
Deswegen X.
Das Letzte, was wir probiert haben, ist Sway,
was ja quasi so eine I3-Abklatsch für Wayland ist.
Selbst das hat nicht richtig funktioniert.
Der Stream ist noch gar nicht so lang her.
Ja, dass Hyperland und solche Sachen nicht gescheit in der VM funktionieren, verständlich.
Aber solange das der Fall ist,
solange bei Wayland die typische Linux-Open-Source-Diskussion immer ist,
das ist kein Wayland-Problem.
Nein, das ist kein Desktop-Problem.
Das ist ein Grafik-Treiber-Problem.
Nein, das ist ein Frame-Buffer-Problem.
Das ist ein Kernel-Problem.
Nein, das ist ein Mesa-Treiber-Problem.
Das ist ein OpenGL-Implementierungs-Problem.
Ah, nee, der Vulkan-Wrapper ist das Problem.
Nee, eigentlich ist das Problem, dass Glibc die falsche Version hat.
Ja, aber wenn du die richtigen C++-Bindings...
Also, ne?
Solange das wieder die typische Open-Source-Entwicklungs-Wahnsinn hat,
wie es bei manchen Linux-Projekten eben so abgeht,
dann...
...sehe ich mich in nächster Zeit auch nicht Wayland hier auf dem Desktop verwenden.
Nicht, weil ich was dagegen hätte, sondern einfach, weil es nicht richtig funktioniert.
Das geht schon mit so einfachen Sachen los wie Notification-Icons
oder so popelige Sachen wie...
Ja, ich hab keine Windows, ich hab keine Windows-Fenster,
deswegen hab ich keine Icons.
Anwendungs-Icons und sowas.
Ja?
Aber...
Deswegen, das wird erstmal auf unbestimmte Zeit auf X-Org-Basis bleiben,
weil Wayland schlicht und ergreifend einfach nicht funzt.
Ich würd's ja...
Ich hab's...
Leute, und mir kann noch nicht mal irgendjemand vorwerfen,
ich würde es nicht probieren.
Wir haben jährlich hier im Stream, und das seit ich streame,
ich glaub, eines der ersten Streams...
Okay, damals hab ich mit Fabian noch ein bisschen Black Desert gespielt,
aber als ich angefangen hab, Linux-Sachen hier auch zu streamen,
eines der ersten Streams war Wayland.
Und damals war Wayland noch...
Das ist Jahre her, ja?
Und damals haben sie auch schon erzählt, ah, Alter, Wayland, beste, musst du verwenden.
Damals konnte Wayland noch nicht mal Fenster skalieren.
Wenn ich damals in Wayland Fenster skaliert hab,
das ist jetzt schon Jahre her, das geht mittlerweile besser,
wenn ich Fenster skaliert hab in Wayland, also quasi so,
dann hat sich nicht der Inhalt skaliert,
sondern die Auflösung.
Dann hab ich ein Fenster aufgemacht und hab das raufskaliert,
dann war das Fenster auf einmal pixelig,
weil der Inhalt geskalt hat und nicht...
Also nicht, weil der Inhalt geskalt hat,
sondern weil das einfach nur den Ausschnitt skaliert hat.
Ganz, ganz weirdes Zeug, ja?
Das geht mittlerweile.
Aber es ist immer noch ziemlich kaputt.
Hyperland funktioniert gar nicht.
Gar nicht in der VM.
Das lasse ich mir noch gefallen irgendwo,
ja, aber Sway funktioniert auch nicht.
Nächstes Jahr probieren wir es wieder.
Auf Native-Kisten funktioniert Wayland in der Tat halbwegs brauchbar.
Ich hab mir so ein Mini-PC gekauft
und darauf Wayland laufen mit Hyperland.
Das funktioniert ganz okay.
Wenn man sich auch ein bisschen umgewöhnen muss.
Meinst du x ehemals Twitter?
Ja, klar.
Arch Linux ist aber nicht für Anfänger, oder?
Wie Anfänger?
Noch nie was unter Linux gemacht?
Dann nicht.
Dann scheiterst du wahrscheinlich schon an einer Installation.
Wenn du ein bisschen was unter Linux gemacht hast, schon.
Weil die Installation ist gar nicht mehr schwer.
Also die Installation ist im Vergleich zu früher wirklich easy geworden.
Du hast ein Setup,
das sieht vielleicht nicht so fancy aus wie ein Linux-Mint-Installer,
ist aber easy zu bedienen.
Der Arch-Installer, den hast du auch in 5 Minuten durchgetippt.
Den kannst du halt nicht durchklicken.
Aber ganz für Anfänger würde ich sagen, ist das nix.
Weil selbst wenn du Arch über den Arch-Installer installiert hast,
hast du immer noch ein nackiges System.
Also für Einsteiger ist es nix.
Wenn du Einsteiger bist, der schon ein bisschen Ahnung hat und sagst,
hey, ich suche ein System, wo ich wirklich was lerne über Linux,
indem ich mich damit beschäftige,
dann ist Arch Linux wahrscheinlich das Beste, was du verwenden kannst.
Weil wenn du...
Wenn du vorhast, dir das selbst einzurichten,
dann wirst du über so viele Hürden stolpern,
wo du dich drum kümmern musst.
Aber wenn du es gelöst hast alles, dann hast du auch was gelernt, ja.
Hast du Backups außer Haus?
Ein Kumpel ist neulich die Bude abgefackelt.
Er hat wirklich nix mehr außer die Sachen.
Ich weiß nicht, ob das wirklich außer Haus zählt.
Ich hab...
Okay, ich hab was außer Haus,
aber nicht außer Grundstücke.
Und auch nur das Wichtigste.
Ich hab nen USB-Stick.
Ich glaub, das ist ein 256-Gig USB-Stick.
Da sind ein paar Sachen drauf.
Unter anderem eine Kopie von meinem Passwortsafe.
Weil das das größte Problem ist, was man hat,
dass man sich nicht gescheit einloggen kann.
Und ein paar Sachen. Handy-Backups sind drauf.
Ja, also Sachen, die ich wirklich nicht verlieren will.
Nicht viel, da ist nicht viel drauf.
Und das Ganze ist doppelt und dreifach verschlüsselt.
Also das ist quasi nen...
N'Lux Volume.
Ja, es ist kein VeraCrypt Volume.
Es ist n'Lux Volume.
N'Lux Volume.
Und der Passwortmanager ist auch nochmal verschlüsselt.
Also...
Und die Passwörter sind richtig lang.
Also selbst wenn das irgendjemand klaut,
hat er da keine Chance, was mit anzufangen.
Als Einsteiger, wenn du Linux zum...
Als Einsteiger suchst, würde ich dir auch Linux Mint empfehlen.
So wie das der Chat gerade irgendwo gemacht hat.
Find's jetzt gerade nicht.
Ja, hier, genau.
Ja.
Linux Mint ist ein gutes Einstiegssystem.
Das...
Muss auch...
...wirklich was dran sein,
dass das immer empfohlen wird als Einstiegssystem.
Weil...
Ich hab meinem Vater ne Kiste mit Linux Mint...
...geschenkt.
Der erinnert sich noch einmal an mein
Bartos-Serra-Video.
Die Kiste hab ich platt gemacht und Linux Mint drauf installiert
und meinem Vater geschenkt.
Die verwendet er jetzt
und der scheint damit klar zu kommen.
Der ruft mich äußerst selten an,
wenn es um Linux-Probleme geht.
Der macht damit aber auch nix.
Muss man sagen.
Ich hab automatische Updates eingeschaltet.
Dass ich das Ding automatisch update.
Ich hab Teamviewer drauf gemacht,
dass ich zur Not gucken kann.
Aber ich hab schon bestimmt 2 Monate jetzt nicht mehr geguckt.
Also der kommt damit anscheinend einfach klar.
Aber der macht auch nix.
Der macht nix.
Der macht Chrome auf dem Desktop.
Und der macht Chrome auf. Fertig.
Das war's.
Das ist alles, was der mit diesem Rechner macht.
Chrome öffnen.
Und ab und zu macht der YouTube auf und macht Musik so laut an,
dass die Nachbarn abgefuckt sind.
Aber das war's. Mehr macht der nicht.
Und dafür ist das echt ganz okay.
Und er kommt damit klar.
Und es war auch Zeit,
weil ich hatte ihm ja meinen alten Computer
gegeben.
Einen alten Big Tower.
Noch.
Also meinen vorletzten Rechner.
Der mit der
Xeon CPU.
Der ging allerdings
noch mit Windows 11 zu installieren.
Und da war Windows 11 drauf.
Und er hatte.
Jaja, der hatte da vor Windows.
Und er hatte so viel Scheiße wieder auf seinem Windows Ding.
Den PC
PC Tune Up.
Und Bitdefender
Antivirus.
Verschiedene Antiviren.
Alter, ich weiß nicht, was mit den Leuten
immer falsch ist, was sie da treiben.
Und diese, diese, diese
PC Tuning Engine und was auch immer alles.
Das Zeug lässt sich
gar nicht mal deinstallieren.
Und irgendwann hat er es geschafft,
dass die Grafik, der Grafikkartentreiber kaputt war.
Frag mich nicht wie.
Und da wollte ich einfach. Hab ich gesagt, okay, weißt was.
Wir laden uns einfach von AMD
die neuesten Treiber runter und installieren die drüber.
Ich konnte nicht.
Der Windows Rechner war so verhunzt.
Ich konnte nicht mal einen
Grafikkartentreiber installieren.
Das hast du angeklickt und dann hat er irgendwie
Unknown Error.
Das war so kaputt.
Innerhalb von einem dreiviertel Jahr.
Das ich mir gedacht habe, okay, es gibt jetzt zwei Varianten.
Entweder.
Ich überlasse den, ich überlasse den einfach.
Einfach, ja, sich selbst.
Oder.
Er muss jetzt eine Linux Kiste verwenden.
Sonst drehe ich durch.
Ja.
Und seitdem hat er Linux Mint.
Der hat mich bestimmt,
bestimmt zwei Monate schon nicht mehr angerufen.
Dass da irgendwas
kaputt ist oder so.
Das scheint einfach zu funktionieren.
Aber wie gesagt, der macht auch nichts.
Der macht Chrome auf und das war's.
Unter Linux
gibt es so Tune-Up Tools nicht.
Also so
bloatware Tune-Up Tools, ne.
Du hast Tools unter Linux,
die du benutzen kannst, um manche Sachen einzustellen.
Aber das ist dann keine,
ich optimiere deinen PC mit Tricks,
die nicht mal Microsoft kennt, bloatware Geschiss.
Ja, du kannst Power Top
aufmachen, um Energiespar-Settings einzustellen
und sowas. Das kannst du machen.
Aber nur, wenn es sinnvoll ist und wenn du das machen willst.
Aber diesen anderen
Shit gibt es nicht.
Weil es ja auch keinen Sinn macht.
Weil die Dinger machen ja unter Windows auch nichts
sinnvolles.
Ich habe echt keine Ahnung,
wie die Leute das immer schaffen.
Du kannst Ubuntu nehmen, das geht auch.
Aber ich würde Mint nehmen.
Ich finde Mint einstiegsfreundlicher und konsistenter.
Nimm Mint Cinnamon Edition
und gut ist.
Ich habe mich eingetragen
für die Alpha. Ich wurde anscheinend
freigeschaltet auch, weil es ist jetzt in Steam
zum Spielen, ja.
Aber ich habe mir da gestern ein paar Gameplays
von angeguckt
und bin zu dem Schluss gekommen,
das Game sieht zwar aus
auf den ersten Blick,
wie Warzone
verheiratet mit Battlefield.
Aber wenn man sich das
etwas im Detail anguckt,
stellt man fest, dass das ein, zumindest wirkt das auf mich so.
Und ich habe wohl gemerkt, ich habe es noch nicht
gespielt und ich bin wirklich am überlegen,
ob ich es spielen sollte. Erstmal ist es ein China-Chinesen
Game, keine Ahnung, ob ich es installieren will.
Aber unabhängig davon.
Ich habe mir gestern 2-3 Stunden
Gameplay nebenbei angeguckt.
Bei ähm...
Wie heißt der auf
Twitch?
Den habe ich auch mal gehostet.
Der spielt hauptsächlich Battlefield.
Ah, ich habe den Namen vergessen.
TC...
Nicht Equa...
Das ist ein deutsch-englischsprachiger Streamer.
TC Bounty oder so?
Kann das sein?
Der hat immer nur 20 Zuschauer oder so.
Aber bei dem gucke ich ab und zu mal Battlefield.
Der hat das gestreamt, ich habe es gestern nebenbei laufen lassen.
Und ich hatte den Eindruck,
dass das ein Mobile Game ist,
was Bots ingame hat.
Also was echte Spieler
und Bots mischt.
Ich bin mir da nicht abschließend sicher gewesen,
ob die Leute nicht einfach
wirklich nur so dumm sind.
Aber ich würde sagen,
das ist ein Mobile Game mit Bots
und ein paar Spielern.
Und das ist was, wo ich sage,
da habe ich eigentlich keinen Bock drauf.
Also die Laufgeschwindigkeit erscheint mir alles
sehr gemächlich.
Und...
Das wirkte wie
optisch quasi wie
Warzone plus Battlefield.
Aber vom...
Gameplay Aspekt wirkte es auf mich
eher wie ein Mobile Game.
Jetzt auch nicht mit wahnsinns Tiefe.
Und vor allem mit Bots.
Und das hat mich dann
nicht so überzeugt.
Also ich glaube nicht, dass das der nächste
Warzone oder Battlefield Killer ist.
Wobei ein Battlefield Killer brauchen wir nicht.
DICE macht das die letzten Jahre
über ja schon ganz gut.
Die haben das ja selbst gekillt.
Geben wird es ihn sicherlich noch.
Videos machen nicht mehr.
Ja das kannst du dir überlegen.
Also ich würde dir empfehlen,
wenn du dich einfach nur mal
mit Linux auseinandersetzen willst,
installiere dir das in der VM.
Installiere dir das in der VM,
weil dann hast du den großen Vorteil,
wenn du nicht weiter kommst,
dann kannst du immer noch auf Windows switchen,
dort nach dem Fehler suchen,
dann unter Linux fixen,
installiere es dir in der VM.
Wenn du wirklich ganz neu bist,
komplett neu, gar keine Ahnung,
nimm dir vor allem eine Workstation
installiere dir Linux Mint da drinnen,
installiere dir die VMware Tools,
falls die nicht standardmäßig dabei sind,
mittlerweile, weil ansonsten hast du
hier kein Fullscreen und so.
VMware Tools installieren
und gut ist.
Und dann kannst du dich mit Linux Mint
ein bisschen auseinandersetzen.
Ich würde sie in der VM installieren.
Gerade wenn man ganz neu ist.
Ich hoffe ja drauf,
also das neue Battlefield scheint ja schon
in Entwicklung zu sein,
ich hoffe ja drauf, dadurch,
dass sie jetzt ein paar andere
Leute bei DICE in der Chefetage
haben,
dass vielleicht, also
sagen wir mal so,
ich habe komplett die Hoffnung aufgegeben,
dass ein richtig echtes Battlefield,
was sich für mich
anfühlt wie Battlefield
und spielt wie Battlefield,
jemals wieder rauskommt.
Da habe ich abgeschlossen.
Ich glaube, wir werden niemals
wieder ein Battlefield erleben,
was sich einfach,
so nach Battlefield spielt,
wie das
Teile gemacht haben.
So, ich finde
ja mit Battlefield 1 hat das schon
nachgelassen. Battlefield 1 war wenigstens
noch gut gemacht, aber das
ging mit Hardline schon bergab.
Naja, und
ich habe mich damit abgefunden, dass
es kein Battlefield
mehr geben wird,
was sich wie Battlefield spielt
und wie Battlefield anfühlt oder eben
halt auch so simple Sachen hat,
wie was aus meiner Sicht essentiell
ist für ein ordentliches Multiplayer-Spiel
auf dem PC Server Browser.
By the way, ich habe das von Anfang
an gesagt,
bei Battlefield 2042.
Ich habe das von Anfang an gesagt.
Ich habe gesagt, die werden so
eine Art Skill-Based Matchmaking machen
und der einzige Weg,
das, es ist ein Battlefield 2042
nicht so krass, muss man sagen,
der einzige Weg, wie man das erreichen
kann, ist keinen Server Browser.
Und dann haben alle gesagt, Max,
das kann überhaupt nicht sein.
Und was war zum Release, haben sie es zugegeben,
es gibt keinen Server Browser.
Ich habe das von Anfang an gesagt.
Das ist der einzige Weg, wie du das machen kannst.
Das war der einzige, wenn man mal drüber nachgedacht hat,
der einzige sinnvolle Weg.
Ja, und natürlich gibt es immer noch die Fans,
die gesagt haben, ja, aber es gibt doch einen Server Browser.
Ja, es gibt diese komischen Custom-Server,
die KaiSau spielt.
Das war von Anfang an klar.
Das würde ja auch falsch liegen können,
aber für mich war das von Anfang an logisch.
Was ich mir vorstellen könnte ist,
dadurch, dass die jetzt mal
ein paar neue Leute
dabei haben, auch was die Chefetage
bei DICE angeht,
die vielleicht nicht mehr
so von sich überzeugt sind,
dass alles, was sie machen, eh immer automatisch
das Richtige ist,
die vielleicht auch mal
in der Lage sind, man muss sich das ja mal überlegen,
man muss sich das mal wirklich auf der Zunge zergehen lassen,
erinnert sich vielleicht noch einer an den Bericht
von einem der ehemaligen
DICE-Mitarbeiter, der gesagt hat,
du durftest bei DICE,
also, das ist jetzt kein Zitat,
das ist jetzt sinngemäß, so wie ich das im Kopf habe,
der gesagt hat,
du durftest bei DICE
Gameplay-Fehler nicht mehr ansprechen,
weil sich sonst jemand verletzt gefühlt hat,
der dieses Gameplay-Feature eingebaut hat.
Und ohne Scheiß,
genau so fühlt sich
Battlefield 42 an.
Man hat irgendwas eingebaut
und hatte Schiss, es wieder auszubauen,
weil irgendjemand sich dann angepisst fühlt.
Aber das ist halt das Problem,
so entstehen eben im Endeffekt
keine guten Sachen.
Gute Sachen entstehen dadurch, dass man was ausprobiert
und auch
in der Lage ist, das was nicht funktioniert
rauszuschmeißen und die guten Sachen
zu behalten, beziehungsweise die guten Sachen
zu verfeinern.
Kann mir keiner erzählen, dass beispielsweise
nehmen wir mal irgendwie ein gutes
Game als Beispiel, nehmen wir mal Warcraft 3
oder Half-Life oder whatever,
ist eigentlich egal,
dass dort instant
alles perfekt war.
Garantiert nicht.
Die Spiele waren auch nicht umsonst teilweise ewig in Entwicklung.
Da wurde viel ausprobiert.
Es wurde viel eingebaut und es wurde viel rausgeschmissen.
Es gibt ja manchmal,
manchmal werden ja noch irgendwelche Beta-Builds geleakt
oder sowas, wo teilweise Sachen grundsätzlich unterschiedlich waren.
Du musst Sachen einbauen,
du musst sie ausprobieren, was natürlich auch dazu
führt, dass die Entwickler ihren eigenen Shit
spielen müssen, was sie ja mittlerweile auch nicht mehr machen,
weil sie sich für ihre eigenen Games null interessieren.
Und dann stellst du
fest, ey, das funktioniert,
das muss man vielleicht noch ein bisschen tweaken,
bis es noch besser wird,
oder es funktioniert gar nicht und man schmeißt es wieder raus.
Aber sobald man irgendwie so eine Kultur hat,
jemand baut was ein,
und Kritik ist unerwünscht,
weil dann könnte sich jemand verletzt fühlen,
der es eingebaut hat.
Keine Ahnung,
was da los ist.
Ich verstehe ein bisschen
den Gedanken dahinter,
man möchte eine möglich positive Arbeitsatmosphäre
schaffen, aber ich finde,
das schafft keine positive Arbeitsatmosphäre,
wenn man sich anguckt, was gleichermaßen passiert.
Auf der einen Seite, so nach dem Motto,
oh, wenn du ansprichst, dass was nicht gut funktioniert,
bist du da böse,
aber man macht 50%
Überstunden, damit er
scheißfertig wird und
schläft nicht und alles.
Das ist natürlich sicherlich viel besser für die Arbeitsatmosphäre.
Also ich finde das überhaupt kein Problem,
solange die Leute das auf eine
zwischenmenschlich
angemessene Variante machen.
Also ich finde es auch nicht gut, wenn jetzt irgendjemand
was einbaut, so ein neues Feature,
ausprobiert wird
und das taugt nichts und die Leute dann sagen,
Alter, wie kann man so eine Scheiße einbauen,
du baust immer nur Scheiße ein,
verpiss dich, so sollte das nicht sein.
Aber es muss durchaus
im Rahmen, also wenn man es,
es muss durchaus okay sein zu sagen, ey,
also, ich finde das
Feature passt so nicht in das Gameplay,
weil das, keine Ahnung,
den Gameplay-Fluss
von den M-Comps ablenkt oder sowas.
Das finde ich vollkommen okay
und damit hätte ich persönlich auch kein Problem.
F, F-Programmer, danke für den Sub.
Damit hätte ich auch kein Problem, aber das war ja bei DICE
anscheinend nicht so, wenn man den ehemaligen DICE
Leuten glaubt. Und genau so hat sich
ja auch Battlefield 2042 angefühlt.
Man hat ganz viele Leute daran arbeiten gehabt,
die irgendwas gemacht haben und hatte dann
zu viel Schiss, es wieder rauszuschmeißen.
Gut, und dann kam noch das Hin und Her
mit EA, was Sachen wollte.
So, und ich habe ein bisschen die Hoffnung,
das ist auch die einzige Hoffnung, die ich noch für Battlefield habe,
ist, dass ich durch die Änderung an der
Chefetage daran
vielleicht ein bisschen was geändert
hat.
Weil wirklich gute Battlefield-Entwickler, die mal
ein Battlefield entwickelt haben, ein gutes Battlefield
haben die ja gar nicht mehr, die sind ja alle weg.
Heißt im Endeffekt, die müssen sich das eh alle abgucken.
Ob es so sinnvoll ist, Battlefield
weiter in Frostbite zu entwickeln,
habe ich auch meine Zweifel,
weil die ganzen Engine, Frostbite-Engine-
Pros sind ja auch weg.
Also wahrscheinlich wäre es für Battlefield
eventuell doch sinnvoller,
das in Unreal zu bauen
oder so.
Keine Ahnung.
Zumindest habe ich ein bisschen die Hoffnung,
dass wenn sich vielleicht ein bisschen so die
Mentalität bei DICE ändert
und man sich
tatsächlich auf gescheites Gameplay fokussiert,
dass dann ein gescheites Game
rauskommen wird. Dass dann jemals wieder
ein Battlefield rauskommen wird, was sich wie Battlefield
spielt und wie Battlefield anfühlt
und man denkt, ey das ist durch und durch ein Battlefield.
Das glaube ich nicht, dass das
je wieder passieren wird.
Aber ich glaube, die können durchaus ein gescheites Game
auf die Reihe kriegen.
Und die können auch ein gescheites Battlefield
auf die Reihe kriegen,
was ein gutes Game ist.
Und vielleicht gewinnen sie ja der Sache noch irgendwas Neues ab,
wo du sagst, ey, das fühlt sich vielleicht nicht
mehr so exakt an, wie man es von
Battlefield gewöhnt ist, aber es fühlt sich nach einem eigenständigen
gescheiten Game an,
wo ich
durchaus sagen kann, ja,
das hat ein Spielgefühl, da kann ich mich
daran gewöhnen, dass sich Battlefield so anfühlt.
Aber
das müssen die mal zeigen.
Aber das nächste ist ja mit Sicherheit schon in Entwicklung,
gehe ich ganz stark davon aus.
Ich weiß nicht, ob es dazu schon irgendwelche Leaks
oder Sachen gibt.
Und 2042 ist End of Life.
Könnte böse Zungen würden behaupten, seit Anfang an
End of Life.
Aber es gab ja doch die ein oder anderen Sachen.
Also Battlefield 2042 hat jetzt irgendwie 3 Jahre oder so
nach Release,
ungefähr, wenn auch nicht wirklich genau,
den Umfang von Battlefield 4
zu Release oder so.
Ja.
Also ich bin mal gespannt, was da kommt.
Die sind nicht in Bedrängnis,
die sind eh schon komplett im Arsch.
Ich glaube nicht, dass DICE irgendwie
nach 2042 noch irgendwie ein gutes Standing
dort hat.
Vor allem, wisst ihr, könnt ihr euch noch daran erinnern,
wie die sich rausgeredet haben zum Release?
Weiß
doch jemand, Chat, wer weiß es noch?
Welches Spiel war dafür verantwortlich, dass
Battlefield 2042 so gefloppt ist?
Es war, by the way, nicht Battlefield 2042
selbst.
Natürlich nicht.
Natürlich konnte man nicht zugeben, dass man
scheiße programmiert hat.
Kannst du dich noch mal daran erinnern,
auf welches Game die das geschoben haben?
Battlefield 3 war für mich auch
das Beste, ja.
Battlefield Cyberpunk, ne Halo, richtig, Halo.
Ja.
Halo Infinite, was heute auch keiner mehr spielt.
Ne, Halo.
Sie haben es auf Halo geschoben.
Sie haben es auf Halo Infinite geschoben,
weil es die Leute damals gespielt haben.
Games, die miteinander gar nichts zu tun hatten.
Ich weiß nicht,
es gibt bestimmt so ein paar bisschen
competitive-orientierte Spieler, die beide spielen,
aber ganz ehrlich, ich bin der Meinung, Halo
und Battlefield, das richtet sich an zwei
komplett unterschiedliche Spielertypen.
Ich habe Halo Infinite am Anfang auch gespielt, mir hat es auch Spaß gemacht,
aber das ist vom Spielgefühl her,
das ist was komplett
anderes.
Selbst wenn du Large Team Battles oder wie das
heißt, spielst bei Halo, das ist was komplett
anderes als Battlefield. Komplett.
Was die sich da für eine Scheiße,
die konnten einfach ums Verrenken nicht zugeben,
dass sie Scheiße gebaut haben.
Und wenn sich das ändert, wäre glaube ich schon
ein bisschen was gewonnen.
Was macht der eigentlich?
Guck mal, Battlefield.
Was ist es denn dann? 6?
Ne.
Ach hier, guck mal.
Ah ne, hups. Moment, 7.
Battlefield 7.
Ja, dass es in Arbeit ist, das ist mir auch klar.
Okay, man.
Battle Royale Mode. Och, please.
Leute, jetzt wo der Zug abgefahren ist,
Alter. In 2042
hättet ihr die Chance gehabt.
Aber jetzt, Alter.
Also mal ernsthaft.
Jetzt, 2024.
Der Zug ist doch schon komplett abgefahren.
Ich will nicht sagen, dass
du damit nicht noch irgendwie Kohle, aber das ist komplett durch.
Und ich bin auch immer noch der Meinung,
auf die Art und Weise, wie sie es gemacht haben,
war das,
also Firestorm, ich habe Firestorm,
nie richtig gespielt, ja.
Firestorm war an sich von der Idee her gar nicht schlecht,
dass es halt in einem Paid Game war.
Naja, ich bin der Meinung,
das ist nicht unbedingt das,
wofür man
Battlefield jetzt spielen
will.
Also meiner persönlichen Meinung nach
würde ein Battlefield
immer noch am besten funktionieren,
wenn man sich auf Battlefield konzentriert.
Ich weiß,
aus Dice-Sicht ein Ding der Unmöglichkeit,
ein Battlefield zu bauen, was nach
Battlefield aussieht und sich anfühlt,
das ist ja auch komplett abwegig, oder?
Komplett abwegig.
Also quasi ein Game zu bauen,
was sich konzentriert auf
Rush
und Conquest.
Wie wäre es denn damit?
Und was vielleicht zum Release
einfach auch mal ordentlich
Content bietet,
damit man eben, und nicht einfach nur
Content in Form von Assassin's Creed Style,
wir haben da mal prozedural
100 Maps generiert, nein.
Das Content bietet,
was Feinheiten
hat, ja.
Also wie wäre es zum Beispiel mal mit einem
Battlefield, was rauskommt,
was 20 Maps zum Release hat,
ich weiß nicht, wie viele Maps hatte
Battlefield 3 zum Release? 10 oder irgendwas?
War auch nicht so viel. 8 oder?
1, 2, 3, 4, 5?
Ne, das stimmt überhaupt nicht.
Keine Ahnung, ich weiß es nicht. Zumindest,
wie wäre es denn, wenn die mal ein Game rausbringen,
was 20 Karten zum Release hat
und diese 20 Karten aber auch
Feinheiten haben, ja.
Also coole Momente, sowas wie der Jump in Demoman Peak,
aber auch irgendwie Feinheiten,
wo du sagen kannst, ey,
es gibt Timings, wie du mit deinem
LLV fahren musst, dass du da rechtzeitig da bist
und vor allem, wisst ihr eine Sache,
die ich wirklich sehr vermisst habe
in den letzten Battlefield-Teilen?
Dass die Leute die Maps selbst gespielt
haben. Und man merkt das.
Ja, zum Beispiel,
mal ein Beispiel, mal ein Beispiel, ja.
Erinnert sich noch einer an den
Clusterfuck schlechthin?
Rush, Sandcrossing,
die erste Base. Rush.
Die erste Base.
Ja, das ist die erste.
Alter, was ist das? Vor 12 Jahren.
Can't wait, Alter, Xbox 360.
Könnte ja ein Gameplay von mir fast sein.
Die erste Base, meine ich hier.
Das ist die erste Base, falls da irgendjemand
dran ist. Rechts, rechts hier drinnen.
So, und
ja, hier sieht man es.
Also, das Ding war,
du hast genau gemerkt,
ja, man sieht es in dem Video jetzt nicht richtig,
ja, man hat genau gemerkt,
das habe ich noch irgendwie,
Rush, Sandcrossing, habe ich
da vielleicht ein Video zu?
Sandcrossing, Rush.
Ich bin Attacker. Okay, ich bin,
ja, genau, also, hier,
hier, hier sieht man es wunderbar.
Hier sieht man es wunderbar. Also,
der Spawn,
hier ist der Spawn, so. Und jetzt ist
es so, wenn du es gescheit
machst, was, ich weiß
nicht, warum ich so lahm bin, aber weil wir keine Sprint-Perk
haben, okay, verstehe. Weil ich, weil ich
übelst dämlich spiele.
Das war vom Timing her.
Okay, hier kann ich es zeigen. Hieran
siehst du, die Leute haben diese eigene,
haben die Map gespielt. Die Defender
spawnen, also hier, es geht jetzt um
das M-Com auf B. Die Defender
spawnen genau in dem
Abstand, dass sie es nicht
schaffen können,
den Eingang dicht
zu machen, sodass du nicht
ins Treppenhaus kommst.
Das ist Absicht. Das ist
hundertprozentig Absicht.
Ich bin zu dumm dafür, guck, die Defender
jetzt, ich war viel zu langsam, ja.
Die Defender sind hier, aber was die Defender nicht machen
können, ist, die Defender können nicht von Anfang an
das Treppenhaus dicht machen. Das geht nicht.
Du bist als Attacker, wenn du einen guten Spawn hast,
immer schneller im Treppenhaus,
als dass Defender
es dicht machen können.
Und das sind so Dinge, wo man sieht, ey,
die haben sich ja was dabei
gedacht.
Die haben sich ja was dabei gedacht.
Und ich entdecke teilweise heute
noch, hier
zum Beispiel auch, weiß nicht, ob man das gescheit erkennt,
ja, ich entdecke
teilweise heute noch
auf den Battlefield 3 Maps
Sachen,
wo ich feststelle,
die haben sich was bei
gedacht. Zum Beispiel gibt
es hier, ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher wo,
hier neben dem Container, also es ist
nämlich so, hier du hast, ähm,
wenn du
TDM spielst,
oder Conquest spielst, ich bin mir nicht
ganz sicher, da geht hier hinten in der Ecke mehr ab,
du hast hier eine Parkbank,
da kannst du
dich hinlegen und genau
in diese Straße unter der Parkbank
durchgucken. Das ist auch 100 pro Absicht!
Und das ist gemacht, dass
du nicht quasi
von hier oder hier hinten hinter der Kiste
das Ding upcampen kannst,
ohne dass die Leute eine Chance haben durchzukommen.
Also du merkst das jedes Mal,
wenn du dir das anguckst, die Leute
haben den Scheiß selbst gespielt,
und die haben sich was bei gedacht.
Und das sind halt so Dinger,
die, die
würde ich mir wünschen bei einem neuen
Game, dass ich nicht den Eindruck
hab, ey, die haben einfach Maps gebaut,
die ganz brauchbar aussehen. Nein,
die haben tatsächlich Maps gebaut, warum ist eigentlich die Qualität
so scheiße im Video? Die haben tatsächlich Maps
gebaut...
Spiel ich auf dem PC, oder ist das Xbox?
Leute, wenn das auf dem PC ist, dann ist
ne, das ist, seriously ist das...
Ich spiel doch
mit dem Controller und nicht mit der Maus, oder?
Was ist das für,
für Hardcore-Pepega-Maus, ey, man?
Guck dir das an!
Ey, und auch solche Ecken und sowas,
guck mal, das ist halt...
Das ist auch PC, man hat's ja auch
an den Tasten gesehen. Und das sind auch so Dinger,
dieser Spot
hier, du merkst, da hat sich jemand
was bei gedacht.
Weil, gäbe es diesen Spot nicht,
dann ist es, dann wäre es unmöglich,
dieses Ding zu defenden.
Vorne kannst du nicht, aber
im gleichen Fall haben die Defender ne
Möglichkeit, hier hinten rauszukommen
aus dem Haus, oder sich hier hinten
zu verschanzen in diesem...
in dieser Garage. Aber du kannst es
trotzdem defenden, also du hast als
Defender ne Chance, das zurück
zu erobern, ja, von den Attackern.
Du hast aber auch als Attacker die Chance,
das M-Com zu defenden. Prinzipiell
hast du es als Defender einfacher,
hier die Leute zu überrennen drinnen.
Ja, und das sind so Dinger,
du merkst, genau, hier!
Das ist das nächste, was mir auffällt.
Guck mal, diese
Kisten hier oben, ne?
Hier, diese Kisten.
Die sind genau
so platziert, dass
wenn du hier hochkletterst,
dass du dich hier drauf
legen kannst, und nur
wenn du dich drauf legst,
kannst du hier in den Gang,
wo ich hergekommen bin, reingucken
und defenden.
Aber nur im Liegen, und warum ist das wichtig,
dass es nur im Liegen geht?
Das erste ist,
wobei ich glaube, du kannst hier dahinter
ein bisschen klitschen, das erste ist,
du kannst nicht aus 3 Milliarden Winkeln
die Gegner beschießen, wo du selbst nur schwer
beschossen werden kannst, aber
wenn die dich
quasi
zurückballern wollen,
dadurch, dass du liegen musst,
kannst du nicht einfach abhauen.
Das heißt, du musst dich committen.
Wenn du dich da drauf legst, kannst du gut den Gang defenden,
aber wenn
jemand gut aimt und auf dich schießt,
kommst du nicht weg, weil du liegst.
Also das sind so Dinge, wo ich mir denke, Alter,
da hat sich wirklich einer was bei gedacht, als der
den Kram designt hat. Und sowas vermisse ich
bei ganz vielen neueren Games, wo ich mir denke,
ja okay, Maps, cool gemacht,
alles, aber warum ist
der Defender bitteschön schon an dem Spot,
wenn ich als Attacker beim ersten überhaupt
keine Chance habe und sowas. Und ich finde da,
und es ist wirklich jetzt, ganz ehrlich,
Sandcrossing Rush ist jetzt wirklich keine Karte,
wo ich sagen würde, die ist perfekt
gebaut, ja. Die ist
gerade dieses M-Com ist extrem
Defender-lastig. Also es gibt, wahrscheinlich
sind 70% der Runden
auf Sandcrossing Rush, kommen nicht über dieses
M-Com raus, weil die Defender hier gefühlt mit 40 Leuten
drin hocken, du kommst nicht rein.
Aber selbst als Attacker hast du die Chance,
hier außen rum, hier oben in
den ersten Stock, hier hinten
rum zu flanken mit dem LRV, hier im ersten
Stock, du kannst viel machen.
Und das vermisse ich einfach bei vielen Games,
so diese gewisse Finesse,
wo du merkst, die Leute haben sich was
bei gedacht. So.
Ich hab damals öfters Videos zugemacht,
so meine Empfehlung für das Game,
aber das hat natürlich keinen interessiert, warum sollten
die auf irgendeinen random Dude da mich hören?
Und ich will mit DICE auch nichts
zu tun haben. Außerdem, eine Sache,
also ich bin mir ziemlich sicher,
DICE mag mich nicht mehr seit meinem
Geflame gegen Battlefield 2042.
Muss ich mir überlegen,
ich hatte ja zum Release von Battlefield 2042
eine Kooperation mit DICE.
Oder besser gesagt, mit DICE
ist falsch, mit
den Marketing-Dudes
von EA.
Weil ich übelst gehypt
auf das Game war und mich richtig
gefreut habe und
hier kam
das Game raus.
Ich war hier schon ein bisschen.
Dieses Gameplay,
äh, nee, nicht das Gameplay.
Bin mir gar nicht sicher,
wo das ist. Keine Ahnung.
Ähm, ja.
Ich wurde damals sogar noch zu Events eingeladen
und durfte im Vorfeld capturen
und sowas, ja. Zumindest
kam das, kam das
Game raus und ich habe mich übelst drauf gefreut
und ich habe mit denen ausgemacht,
ich mache zum Release drei Videos,
wo ich jeweils die
unterschiedlichen Aspekte von dem
Spiel zeige, ja. Portal,
ähm,
ja, äh, Specialists
und 120
Spieler und
Hazard Zone. So. Man hat,
ich glaube, man sieht anhand der Videos,
dass meine
Begeisterung für das Spiel relativ
schnell nachgelassen haben, ja.
Das war das erste Video,
was ich zum Release gemacht habe.
Das war schon, da habe ich mir schon gedacht, so ganz
perfekt ist das jetzt auch nicht.
Hier war Portal,
da war ich noch relativ begeistert von Portal,
was man hier mit diesem Logic Editor
machen kann. By the way, es ist auch das einzige Video
dieser Art, was ich kenne,
was sich so im Detail
mit Portal beschäftigt hat.
Wir haben ja da quasi Killstreak
und DM gebaut in Portal,
ne. Hier hatte ich schon
keinen Bock mehr auf das Video und hier hatte ich auch
keinen Bock mehr auf das Video
und zwischenzeitlich habe ich auch ein Video gemacht,
wo ich das Game geflamed habe
und hier nach
waren die etwas stinkig mit mir,
weil die haben quasi eine
Paid Promotion bei mir gekauft,
nicht, dass sie mir
vorgeschrieben haben, was ich sagen soll. Es waren
so Sachen, es waren so Sachen vorgeschrieben,
wie, äh, ich muss
ein Specialist zeigen, ich muss
einen Spielmodus zeigen und sowas,
aber die waren ein bisschen pisst, dass ich quasi
während ich Promotion-Videos
hochgeladen hab, zwischendurch ein Video hochgeladen
hab, wo ich das Spiel übelst geflamed
hab, aber zu Recht, alles was
ich gesagt hatte in dem Video, würde ich
wahrscheinlich heute noch unterschreiben,
äh, außer vielleicht für die paar Sachen, die halt
verbuggt waren, mittlerweile gefixt sind.
Es war halt einfach
nicht das, was
man nach dem ganzen Trailer
und Gehype im Vorfeld
für sich versprochen hat. Es war ein
unfertiges, schlecht
durchdachtes Game mit wenig Content.
Ja. Und da waren die, da waren die
echt ein bisschen pisst auf mich.
Ich hab dann das letzte Video hier noch hochgeladen
von dieser Promotion. Ich hatte
überhaupt keinen Bock auf das Video.
Ich hab mich echt quälen müssen für das Video.
Man sieht das auch. Kein Thumbnail
und nix. Das Lieb-, das ist
eines der lieblosesten Videos, die ich je gemacht
hab. Ich hab halt
unterschrieben, dass ich drei Videos zu Release mache,
ja? Das war auch, ich hab das auch am letztmöglichen
Tag hochgeladen und sowas.
Und
ja, aber was willst du machen, ja?
So, und ich war sogar ganz froh,
dass es keiner geguckt hat, das Video.
Ich glaub, irgendwo steht auch, dass es
Paid Promotion ist.
Ja, hier, unterstützt durch die EA.
Ja, und da war ich echt, da war ich echt enttäuscht,
da, von dem Game. Ja, und seitdem,
seitdem, ja, bin ich da,
bin ich da unten durch. Deswegen glaub ich nicht,
dass sie irgendwie mal wieder
auf die Idee kommen sollten, mich jeweils
zu irgendwas
zu fragen bei neuen Games.
Zumal, zumal die da ja auch überhaupt nicht
daran interessiert sind. Hat man ja schon
bei 2042 gesehen, ich mein,
das ist eine Sache, wo ich hoffe, dass sich das ändert.
Die, äh, hatten ja
früher dieses Game-Changer-Programm,
wo du, wo
die auch teilweise Leute eingeladen haben,
die Feedback geben
sollten zu Battlefield
Spielen in der Entwicklung
und sowas. Aber das,
das war bei Battlefield 2042 schon so,
dass man sich da im Prinzip nur die Leute eingeladen
hat, die alles hypen.
Und das war, Leute,
ich, ich muss es an der Stelle einfach nochmal erzählen,
ich war ja, die haben mich ja damals eingeladen
zu so einem Preview-Event, zu Battlefield
2042, also damals,
wo das,
ich glaube, dort, wo es schon angekündigt war,
aber wo man nicht so viel wiss-, nicht so viel wusste,
wobei, ich bin mir gar nicht
sicher, ob es da schon
angekündigt, doch, ich glaube, es war schon angekündigt.
Zumindest bei diesem Event, Leute,
das war so schlimm. Es war
so cringe auch, ey.
Und zwar,
hatten die da erstmal ein bisschen
Hype-Ansprache gehalten
und am Ende
konntest du quasi in den
Discord
und
du durftest halt ein bisschen spielen. Die haben halt deinen
EA-Account freigeschaltet, dass du, dass du quasi
im Vorfeld schon spielen konntest. So, wir durften
nur, äh, Orbital
spielen. Ist das Orbital? Nee.
Wie heißt die, wie heißt die Map mit der Rakete?
Orbital? Also wahrscheinlich, weil es die Map
war, wo sie gedacht haben, die ist noch am ehesten soweit.
Wir durften ein bisschen in Orbital
spielen und
da hatten sie auch die, diese Wettereffekte
und so übelst drauf gedreht. So.
Und was an diesem Event so extrem,
also wirklich so extrem, ich kann es,
das ist ja, ich hatte so ein,
so ein schlechtes Gefühl
dabei bei dem Event, weil
der, das ist,
das ist enorm schlecht, das ist enorm schwer
zu beschreiben. Ich sag
jetzt einfach mal, wie es ist,
weil das alles solche
unglaublichen Schleimer gewesen
sind dabei. Das ist
Wahnsinn gewesen, ey.
Also zumindest die, die
was gesagt haben, ja.
Der Lost war auch dabei, der hat nicht
geschleimt. Ich glaube, der hatte nach einer halben Stunde schon
keinen Bock mehr auf das Game oder so. Ich weiß nicht mehr.
Ich kann mich nicht mehr richtig
dran erinnern. Ähm,
ne, aber von den Leuten, die was gesagt haben,
die haben alles so extrem,
so hardcore geschleimt.
Das war unglaublich, das habe ich so
noch nicht gesehen. Also,
auch zu unserem Gameplaytest damals
war es offensichtlich,
dass dieses Game nicht fertig ist,
nicht richtig zueinander
passt. Und man hat es damals noch
so ein bisschen quasi
darauf geschoben, das wäre
ja ein Alpha-Bild, das haben sie auch immer wieder
betont. Und ja,
ich meine, wenn man sich überlegt, Battlefield 3 und 4,
die waren auch ziemlich verbuggt zu Release
und sowas. Da hat man das, da wollte man es auch ein bisschen nicht wahr
haben. Aber die Leute haben so krass
rumgeschleimt. Für jeden
Scheiß. Das war einfach,
das war so cringe, sich das anzugucken.
Ja, also auch
die Dinge, also im Prinzip war der gesamte
Discord voll mit
Ultralobpreisungen.
Von den Leuten, die das testen durften.
Also vor allem im
englischsprachigen Bereich.
Ich glaube, im deutschsprachigen Channel
habe ich ein bisschen was geschrieben.
Ich glaube, ich habe damals schon geschrieben, die Wettereffekte
sind einfach viel zu viel.
So nach dem Motto, ich brauche nicht jede Runde
einen Tornado und dann irgendwie so.
Und ein paar andere im deutschsprachigen Chat
haben glaube ich auch noch geschrieben, dass sie irgendwie
Probleme mit den Fahrzeugen hatten und sowas.
Aber der englische Chat, Alter, das
war im Prinzip einfach
nur fünf Seiten
die krasseste Lobpreisung
für Battlefield 2042.
Und ich wette mit euch, die haben auch schon
gemerkt, dass das Game
nicht stimmt. Dass es nicht stimmig
ist bei diesem Playtest. 100 pro.
Und das ist halt das Ding,
wenn du als Content
Creator oder sagen wir mal als
jemand, der ein bisschen Ahnung von der Spielserie hat,
wenn du denkst, du darfst nur noch schleimen,
weil du sonst niemals mehr auf Events eingeladen
wirst, dann läuft schon irgendwas verkehrt.
Dann muss man sich nicht wundern,
wenn die bei jedem Furz,
den sie lassen, denken, sie hätten
quasi das Rad neu erfunden.
Also so nach dem Motto, wir haben
jetzt einen alternativen
Feuermodus eingebaut und alle flippen aus.
Boah, geil! Bestes Feature ever!
Hab ich ja noch nie gesehen, Alter! Ihr habt da richtig
was Großes geschaffen! Ja, wenn die
bei jedem Furz so ausflippen, dann ist ja
kein Wunder, dass sie komplett entkoppelt
von jeglicher Realität sind in dem Entwicklerstudio.
Und selbst spielen sie es ja
nicht mehr. Und ob die gescheite Tester
intern haben, weiß ich auch nicht.
Das ist ja kein Wunder, was da rauskommt, Mann!
Also das war so ein krasses
Cringe-Event.
Da würde ich auch nicht mehr hinwollen.
So. Lange Rede,
kurzer Sinn.
Aber ihr seht,
es ist immer noch eine Spieleserie,
die ich einfach nicht
loswerde im Kopf. Wenn es einfach
scheiße ist, wie das gelaufen ist.
Da geht da wieder komisches Zeug vor.
Bisschen beruhigen jetzt erstmal.
So.
Dann gucken wir doch mal, was
auf GitHub
so trendet heute.
Gucken wir mal, was da so abgeht.
Meinung zu Delta Force. Hab ich grad schon
gesagt. Ich hab's
noch nicht gespielt. Ich bin mir nicht am überlegen.
Alter, was ist das hier?
Die Pelo-Bär-Empfehlung, Alter.
Ey, okay.
YouTube ist echter Meinung.
Ich muss mir unbedingt mal angucken, ja?
Die neue Busstimme.
Ja, ich muss das angucken. Wir gucken das nicht an.
Ey, noch nicht mal,
noch nicht mal.
So, jetzt ist es weg. Ja, das ist das einzige,
wie YouTube teilweise das erklären kann,
wenn du was nicht gucken willst.
Indem du es anklickst
und gleich wieder ausmachst.
Das checkt YouTube manchmal.
Ja, wir wollen uns die aktuellen GitHub-Trends
angucken.
Trending. Trending Weekly.
Also, was haben wir denn?
Deep Package Inspection.
Ne, das brauchen wir nicht. DPI ist schon wieder.
No Code.
Keck, wait, Alter. ConfUI.
Compiler for the C3
Language. Was ist das?
Okay, es ist C auf Rust gemacht
oder was ist es?
Ist es vollständig kompatibel
abwärts zu C?
Dumplix, danke für den Sub.
Welche Range? Weekly. Weekly.
Gucken wir mal. Web-Apps sind
Python, juckt mich nicht.
Wie kennen wir?
Easy Spider.
China-Chinesen-Webcrawler oder sowas.
Gibt es gute Guides oder
Tutorials für Linux? Ja. Millionen.
AI, AI.
Okay, diese Woche ist sehr
unspektakulär und
nicht spannend. Kann man nicht auch
auf die drei Punkte und nicht interessiert auswählen?
Das kannst du machen, das Problem
ist nur, ich bin nicht eingeloggt.
Deswegen geht das nicht.
Also GitHub Trends war wirklich, wirklich
schwache Woche. Das da meinst du
sieht gar nicht verkehrt aus. Okay.
Ist es
Python Web-Assembly oder was?
No need to learn JavaScript. Das wird
im Endeffekt doch eh nicht.
Oder cross-compile das irgendwie zu
JavaScript dann.
Oder Web-Assembly das.
Es ist auch quasi so ein bisschen wie Blazor,
nur die Python-Variante
von Blazor.
Korrekt.
Ich bin der Meinung,
sowas ist overrated,
debated.
JavaScript ist eine ganz gute Sache
für Web-Frontend-Sachen.
Deswegen mag ich Blazor
auch nicht. Blazor hat noch ein paar andere Probleme.
Das es ewig lädt und sowas, ja, aber
ansonsten ist es, wenn man es machen möchte,
okay.
Aber ich bin wie Stuhlmonger, danke für den Zap.
Ich muss ehrlich sagen, ich finde
JavaScript für das Frontend echt nicht verkehrt.
Oh, Chat-Gil.
Chat, bin gleich wieder da.
So.
Da bin ich wieder.
Ja, das kommt ja unterm Strich aufs Gleiche raus.
Ob du TypeScript
oder JavaScript benutzt.
Am Ende ist es JavaScript.
So, machen wir den Kram hier mal zu gerade.
Den VM-Champ
wollten wir noch fixen.
By the way.
Hört mir da gerade auf.
Aber nicht jetzt.
Jo. Lass uns mal kurz auf YouTube gucken, was es da so gibt.
Was ist das?
Why is C++
documentation so bad?
Ich weiß nicht, warum ich das aufgemacht hab.
Wahrscheinlich, weil ich mich bestätigt hören
fühle, dass C++ sagt.
Jetzt hören wir uns jetzt mal an.
Warum C++ Documentation so bad ist.
Ich kann euch aus meiner Sicht
sagen, warum C++ Documentation so
bad ist.
Aus meiner Sicht ist C++
Documentation so bad, weil
C++ so bad ist.
Und die Beschreibung von was
Schlechtem ist
meistens auch schlecht.
Nicht verständlich.
Guck mal, was er sagt.
Blazor Stream. Wir haben schon mal
einen Blazor Stream gemacht. Aber da war es ganz
neu und hat nicht richtig funktioniert.
Vielleicht sollten wir nochmal einen neuen Blazor Stream
machen. Ja, ihr habt Recht.
Aber wie gesagt, ich bin kein großer Blazor
Fan. Ich bin mal gespannt, ob mich das überzeugt.
Okay.
Wow, wow, wow, viel zu lauter.
How many of you have looked at
C++ Documentation before and
thought to yourself, like, what the f***?
Look at this example. What am I actually looking at here?
Das ist ein gutes Beispiel für, wie
abf*** das ist, ja.
C++ Documentation page. Yeah, if you look at more
complicated ones, Forward is a very interesting
one. I'll give each one of you...
Ja.
Beste Sache überhaupt, ja.
Die haben noch nicht mal eine
einfache Beschreibung, was es eigentlich sein soll.
A hundred dollars if you can read
this and tell me exactly how Forward behaves
in C++. I'm talking about the beginners here.
Obviously easy syntax, ja.
If as a beginner you're learning C++ and you come across
C++ and you're trying to understand what it does
and you come to the documentation and you look at
this header, you look at C++ Forward, okay, there's
four different modes here, fair enough, and you start
reading this, at the end of it you just end up with a headache.
And to make matters even worse, like, what
are these examples? Who in their right mind is
kind of writing these examples and thinking, but these things
here are actually useful to beginners.
Die Dinger sind noch nicht mal
useful zu etwas intermediate,
fortgeschrittenen Leuten.
Die sind einfach, die Beschreibung ist einfach
komplett wir. Mal gucken.
Okay, Leute, ich predikte, ich predikte jetzt.
mal was.
In den Kommentaren
werden ganz viele Hardcore C++
Fans sein und die werden das aus irgendwelchen
Gründen verteidigen.
Die werden sagen,
okay, was, okay, lass mich mal kurz
in das Mindset eines C++
Fans reinversetzen.
Was könnte man darauf sagen? Ich finde,
das ist ein wirklich guter, legit
Punkt, den er hier bringt.
Weil diese Hilfeseiten sind wirklich
grausamst scheiße.
Was könnte denn C++ Fan sagen?
Okay, ich weiß, was
ein C++ Fan sagen kann.
C++ Fan sagt,
es ist wichtiger,
eine ausführliche Beschreibung zu haben
als gute Beispiele.
Oder sowas in der Richtung
sagen die als Antwort.
Passt mal auf. Okay,
lass mal gucken. Okay, nicht ganz,
aber so ähnlich, ja.
The site is not intended for beginners.
It's meant to be
seriously. Okay.
Not beginner friendly.
It assumes you are somewhat familiar.
Okay.
Okay, es ist nicht exakt das, was ich gesagt
habe, aber ähnlich, ja.
Ja, es ist, also,
es schlägt in die gleiche Kerbe.
Es schlägt in die gleiche Kerbe.
Also, ich habe gesagt, die sagen, es ist wichtiger,
dass es ausführlich ist als gute Beispiele.
Das sagen sie so nicht, aber es ist
ähnlich. Aber es ist ähnlich.
Es ist ähnlich, was sie sagen.
Ähm.
Das Ding ist,
wenn die hier sagen, jetzt mal
eine Sache. Die sagen, diese
Seite ist nicht für Beginner, es ist,
es muss super precise sein, oder?
It is not a documentation, it's time to translate
C++ standard from
standard to something that humans...
Also, da würde ich erst mal sagen, was
ist der Sinn von einer
Webseite? Also, was ist
der Sinn dieser Seite überhaupt?
Wenn das angeblich der Sinn ist.
Also, er schreibt ja, der Sinn der Webseite ist es,
den C++-Standard
von, ja, nenn's mal,
C++-Standard-Speak
in etwas zu übersetzen,
was Menschen verstehen können.
Ja, aber Menschen können es nicht richtig
verstehen. Was ist der Sinn einer
Seite, etwas von
unverständlich zu übersetzen in
minimal verständlicher?
Was ist der Sinn
davon? Sollte der Sinn nicht sein,
etwas Unverständliches
übersetzen in etwas, was man
gut verstehen kann?
Das ist doch der komplette Unsinn,
dieses Argument.
Don't cry so much. Danke für den
Sub. Und hier hätte ich
auch noch eine Frage, wenn er hier sagt,
diese Seite ist nicht für Beginner.
Es ist gedacht,
dafür besonders präzise zu sein, nicht
beginner-friendly. Also, jetzt mal ernsthaft.
Jetzt mal, ich hab
hier mal eine wirkliche Frage. Gibt es irgend
wirklich jemand, einer, der eine Referenzseite
startet und explizit das Ziel
hat, nicht Einsteiger-Fragen
freundlich zu sein? So nach dem Motto,
ich erstelle eine Hilfeseite,
aber eines meiner erklärten Ziele ist,
ich möchte eine Hilfeseite erstellen, die
nicht Einsteiger-freundlich ist. Die soll
alles andere sein, als Einsteiger-freundlich.
Da kann ich's doch eigentlich auch gleich lassen, oder?
Wofür die ganze Energie
reinstecken, wenn eines der Hauptziele ist,
nicht Einsteiger-freundlich zu
sein? So, aber,
meine eigentliche Frage an ihn wäre
jetzt, wo ist denn die
Einsteiger-freundliche Variante davon?
Ja, microcontroller.net
ist wieder was. Ja, ist auch.
Wo ist denn die Einsteiger-freundliche Variante
davon?
Also, wenn das ja quasi die super
precise, not beginner-
friendly Variante ist, wo ist denn die
Einsteiger-freundliche Variante? Also,
ich wüsste keine. Ich finde es
geil, die C++-Fans sind von sowas
immer ultra getriggert, aber ich finde, es liegt einfach
auf der Hand,
dass es so ist, dass er
Recht hat, ja?
Some
documentation go the other
way, that's too simple. Das stimmt,
aber, das eine schließt
das andere ja nicht aus. Also es ist ja durchaus
okay,
eine Dokumentationsseite zu bauen,
die einfache Beispiele bietet,
aber auch
advancede Beispiele hat. Eventuell
sogar, dass du umschalten kannst,
oder einen Dropdown hast, oder whatever.
Ja? Nein, nein, nein!
Der miss-understand-et nix!
Die Sprache
Und die Seite ist einfach kacke.
Hey, wie sind die JavaScript-Referenzen?
Ja, die sind nicht schlecht.
Mozilla Array Sort.
Die sind gut.
Die JavaScript-Referenz-Seiten von Mozilla.
Die sind...
Also, seriously.
Ihr wollt...
Der will doch nicht wirklich sagen,
dass das hier auf einem ähnlichen Niveau ist wie...
Wie fucking das hier.
Und das ist doch eines der besseren Dinger.
Ja, das geht noch.
Die JavaScript-Referenz hier,
gerade das Ding bei Mozilla,
das ist echt nicht schlecht.
Vor allem, guck mal.
Das macht eine Sache,
die fangen an mit einer Erklärung,
was es macht.
Ja?
Sort Method of Array.
Sort Element of an Array in place.
Du hast einen Satz, der sagt dir,
was es macht und auch gleich das Größte,
worauf du achten musst.
Fertig.
Das schaffen die...
Das schafft die C++-Referenz nicht.
Also, die wollen mir nicht ernsthaft erzählen,
dass das...
What the fuck?
Dass das in irgendeiner Art und Weise
auch nur ansatzweise vergleichbar ist miteinander.
Aber die C++-Leute sind eh so merkwürdig drauf.
Zum Beispiel...
Vector.
Ja?
Schnell, Vector.
C++-Referenz.
Vector hat keine Sort-Methode,
wie beispielsweise das Array in JavaScript.
Der erste Satz.
Der erste Satz ist nicht,
was ein Vector ist.
Was ein Vector ist, steht hier bei 1.
Aus irgendwelchen Gründen.
Was auch immer.
Warum steht nicht als erster Satz
das hier?
Warum ist das...
Warum ist nicht das der erste Satz?
Hier drinnen.
Ja, und das ist noch eines der besseren Seiten hier.
Ja, also, sagen wir mal so.
Vector hat keine Sort-Methode,
wie beispielsweise hier das dynamische...
Also, Vector und Array in JavaScript
sind ziemlich ähnlich.
Denn Array in JavaScript ist ja nicht wirklich ein...
Array, ein Fixed-Array, wie in C,
sondern ein dynamisches.
Ja, da kannst du beliebig viele rein.
Also, Vector und Array in JavaScript
ist ziemlich genau das Gleiche.
Und das hier hat eine Sort-Methode.
Das hier hat keine Sort-Methode.
Okay?
Kann man mitleben.
Kann man sagen, ist ein bisschen doof,
dass es keine Sort-Methode hat.
Aber ist okay.
Und das trägert die C++-Fans immer noch so.
Weil die springen auf sowas total an,
wenn du sowas ansprichst.
Ich finde, es ist...
Es liegt auf der Hand, dass sowas fehlt.
Ja, ich meine, Vector sortiert.
Die sagen dann, ja, warum braucht Vector denn eine Sort-Methode?
Du kannst doch auch einfach
Standard-Sort-Back-Inserter verwenden.
Kein Witz.
Also hier, Sort-Vector-C++.
Also, mal der Vergleich.
In einer ordentlichen Programmiersprache...
In einer ordentlichen Programmiersprache
machst du sowas hier.
Und das ist schon...
Bezeichnen, wenn ich sage,
in einer...
Das ist ordentlich JavaScript.
JavaScript ist auch alles anders ordentlich, ja.
Sorting Vector in C++.
Schauen wir doch mal.
Schauen wir uns doch mal die Erklärung an.
Sehr gut übersichtlich alles.
Schauen wir mal.
So.
What?
Was sind das für Beispiele wieder?
Ja, das hier.
Das hier.
Das hier braucht man.
Und das ist...
Das ist...
Guck mal.
Dieses Beispiel...
Es sorten...
Es ist kein Beispiel.
Die meisten Leute wollen Vektor sortieren.
Gibt's einfach nicht.
Da musst du dann...
Da musst du dann zu Stackoverflow.
So.
Und dann erfährst du,
dass du machen musst...
Erstmal 50 Varianten gibt.
Und dann erfährst du,
dass die richtige Variante,
einen Vektor zu sorten...
What the fuck?
Ihr befindet euch noch nicht mal,
wenn man danach sucht.
Die richtige Variante ist...
Ja, Moment.
Das ist in place.
Ich will ja nicht in...
In...
Place.
Nee, Moment.
Moment mal...
Nee, hä?
Jetzt bin ich...
Jetzt bin ich verwirrt.
Wie ging das?
Ach, nee.
Nicht sort.
Sorry, nicht sort.
Filter will ich haben.
Ähm...
Filter will ich eigentlich haben.
Das suche ich hier.
Das.
In Boost, ja.
Verwende Boost mal auf dem ESP32.
Das hier ist the way, Leute.
Das hier ist the way,
ein Vektor zu...
Und das ist doch die schöne Variante
mit Lambda sonntags, ja?
Das ist the way,
in C++
einen Vektor zu filtern.
Also quasi in ein Array,
nur die Elemente rauszuholen,
die ich haben will.
Guckt euch das mal an.
Also...
What the fuck?
Und die Leute verteidigen das.
Die sagen,
ja, das muss so sein.
Warum sollte Vektor nen...
Ich mein...
Guck mal.
Wir haben...
Wir hätten zur Auswahl...
Ja?
Ey, ist sogar noch ein bisschen zäh.
Also...
Guckt mal, Leute.
Wir hätten zur Auswahl,
es so zu machen wie hier.
Ups.
Also wir hätten die Auswahl,
es so zu machen wie hier.
So, so wie es jetzt in C++ ist.
Oder...
Wie wäre es denn...
Jetzt mal so ne ganz,
GANZ
abgedrehte Frage.
Warum...
Warum gibt es keine Filter-Methode
auf Vektor,
die sowas macht?
Ich mein,
meinetwegen sogar so.
Ja?
Warum gibt es sowas nicht?
Warum...
Warum brauchst du sowas Dummes,
wie Standard-Copy-If?
Warum muss ich überhaupt den Anfang
und das Ende da rein übergeben,
anstatt es nen...
Ne Collection, die nen...
Die...
Die iterable...
Iterierbar ist?
Warum brauch ich...
Sowas Kryptisches,
wie Standard-Back-Inserter?
What the fuck?
Und über die Lambda-Syntax
müssen wir mal gar nicht reden.
Das ist auch das wenigste,
nervigste da dran.
Naja.
Und die...
Und die Referenz ist im Prinzip
genauso, wie er sagt,
für'n Arsch.
Guck mal,
wie das schon anfängt.
Hier steht wenigstens,
was das macht am Anfang.
Also diese Examples...
The fuck?
Wer macht so nen Example, man?
Was ist das für'n Beispiel?
Ach nee, das ist ein Vorschlag,
wie man es implementieren könnte.
Ja, das ist natürlich ganz wichtig.
Ja.
Also, aus meiner Sicht
hat der Typ vollkommen recht.
Nicht der hier.
Der da.
Aber aus meiner Sicht vollkommen recht.
Ja.
Es ist tatsächlich einfacher,
Chat-GPT zu fragen,
wie das funktioniert.
Ja, das stimmt.
Ja, okay.
Okay.
Schön und gut.
Aber wo ist denn die...
Wo ist denn dann
das für Beginners?
Ach ja, ist das so?
Wo gibt's denn...
Wo gibt's denn ne schöne
Referenz
für die Standard-Library
mit Beispielen, die erklärt,
wie man's benutzt?
Die vielleicht auch erklärt,
dass, by the way,
falls sich einer fragt,
ja,
die erklärt, dass...
die erklärt, dass
Standard
Vector
bool
kein Vector of bools ist,
sondern intern in int,
wäre ja manchmal auch ganz praktisch zu wissen, ne?
Nur weil's noch schlechter geht?
Okay.
Wenn das Top-Notch-Documentation
of high quality ist,
dann weiß ich auch nicht.
Ja, das ist aber auch nicht so viel besser.
Da bin ich auch schon manchmal drauf gelandet.
Das ist auch nicht so viel besser.
Ich mein, immerhin.
Immerhin.
Doch, das ist besser.
Das ist besser.
Immerhin
hast du hier ne ordentliche Übersicht,
wo drinsteht,
was es macht.
Direkt im ersten Satz.
Und
sogar ein paar gescheite Beispiele mit Vectors.
Und die Seite ist sogar...
Doch, du...
Doch, doch, Beam, du hast recht.
Die Seite ist besser.
Die ist übersichtlich.
Du hast
einen Satz,
was es macht.
Und du hast ein sinnvolles Beispiel.
Das ist viel besser als
C++ Reference.
Er hat nicht zu allem was drinstehen.
Aber es ist...
Also es ist auf jeden Fall schonmal deutlich besser,
als...
als das andere.
Ja.
Erklärt das auch den Unterschied zwischen Bool Vector?
Ne.
Das ist auch so ein C++ Ding.
Also wer denkt, dass ein Vector Bool
einfach ein Vector mit ganz vielen Bools drinne ist,
der liegt falsch.
The storage is not necessary an array of Bool values.
Also wer jetzt wirklich denkt,
Vector Bool wäre das gleiche wie ein Vector int,
also quasi halt ein Vector mit ganz vielen Ints,
ganz vielen Bools,
ist falsch.
Muss nicht so sein.
Weil C++ shit.
Ja.
Vector Bool ist
der einzige Unterschied
von allen Vektortypen,
die gibt es extra.
Also ein Vector int
ist das gleiche wie ein Vector string,
ist das gleiche wie ein Vector float
oder sonst was.
Halt ein dynamisches Array
mit einer unterschiedlichen Anzahl an Elementen
von diesem Typ.
Außer Vector Bool.
Vector Bool is not necessary.
It is not necessarily an array of Bool Values.
Er war C++ alter.
Meine Güte, ey, so ein Schrott.
So ein Schrott.
Ups.
So, ich brauch jetzt mal irgendwas.
Was haben wir denn hier sonst noch?
Google takes its biggest loss ever.
Nauregons, okay.
Stack-Overfloor-Videos sind immer nice.
Ich find das okay, dass es das gibt.
Hab da gar kein Problem mit.
Ich find's nur blöd,
dass es ein Vector of Bool ist.
Hätten die ne extra Klasse dafür,
dafür die dann keine ahnung keine ahnung bull set oder was weiß ich irgendwie irgendwie anders heißt
dann hätte ich kein problem mit aber es fällt halt komplett aus der reihe und du denkst ja
auch nicht dass das so ist denkst du das wie alles andere kommen wir gucken uns mal das
neueste stack overflow video an changed forever after google lost yesterday big tech changed
forever after google lost the most important legal battle of its life a fight against the
us department of justice that started back in 2020 claiming that google violated us antitrust
law and cheated at monopoly the government called google a filthy monopolist who used illegal
tactics to crush the competition and stifle innovation google's lawyers clapped back and
said that was outrageous and salacious but the judge agreed with the feds guilty and just like
standard oil and the american tobacco company google is now officially required to wear the
illegal
monopoly dunce cap but everyone cheats at monopoly apple amazon and meta are also fighting
active antitrust cases in today's video we'll find out what these cases are all about why
google lost its fight but most importantly what does this mean for the future of big
tech and how do i get rich off of it it is august 6 2024 and you're watching the code
report things used to be a lot different back in the 90s horses were still the primary mode
of transportation hemp was legal and coca-cola still had cocaine in it but 1890 was also
the
year the sherman act was passed a law at the time that was targeted at big oil big tobacco and big
railroad to prevent anti-competitive activities that made it impossible for competitors to enter
the market google broke section 2 of the sherman act which has two provisions the possession of
monopoly power and willful acquisition or maintenance of that power that's not a
consequence of a superior product in other words to break the law you need to both dominate the
market and do so in ways outside of building a better product google controls 88 of the domestic
search market and the other way around you need to both dominate the market and do so in ways outside of building a better product google controls 88 percent of the domestic search
market and i think most people agree that google has a superior product i get way better results
from it than lycos or excite and its ai no longer recommends i jump off the golden bridge when i'm
feeling sad but google got into trouble with its exclusivity deals like when it requires its search
engine to be the default on android devices its deal with the mozilla firefox browser and its
insane deal with apple where it pays them 36 percent of search revenue to the tune of 20
billion dollars per year basically the judge said these deals were anti-competitive and now google
will not pass go
and will not collect 200 well actually we don't really know what the penalty is yet and that's to
be continued in a separate trial i highly doubt it'll be like what jfk said right before he went
to dallas to shatter google into a thousand pieces and scattered into the winds it is possible google
could be broken up into multiple different entities like maybe it has to divest gmail
on android but the tricky thing is it's doch eigentlich jetzt schon oder es ist jetzt ja
eigentlich nicht mal google sondern es ist ja eh alphabet und alphabet besteht ja aus kleinen
kleineren dingen
google ist dass search business so much money it's able to subsidize these free projects
like gmail on android if gmail were on its own we'd probably have to pay ten bucks a month to use it
but if you talk to someone like microsoft who was accused of being a monopoly back in 2001 things
might not be so bad a more likely outcome is that google faces some kind of fine and then contractual
restrictions on these deals and that could actually be a good thing for google because then apple
can't rake in cash while doing absolutely nothing of value except maintain its own monopoly speaking
Das habe ich auch gesehen.
Die kennen wir auch noch.
Wie hieß das Ding?
Ist das die Terranos?
Terranos?
Wie hieß das?
Oder so ähnlich hieß das doch, oder?
Das war?
By the way, nur mal zwei.
Die Firma von der,
die hat ein Healthcare-Produkt hergestellt,
was angeblich mit,
korrigiert mich, wenn ich Mist erzähle,
ich kriege es nicht mehr so ganz aus dem Kopf,
was quasi mit einem Tropfen Blut von dir
ganz viele verschiedene Krankheiten erkennen konnte.
Du musstest quasi nur,
sagen wir mal,
die mussten dir quasi nur einmal einen Finger stechen
und konnten dann erkennen,
ob du einen Gehirntumor hast oder sowas.
Und da haben die Leute damals schon gesagt,
irgendwie,
glauben sie das nicht,
aber die Produkte kamen dann wirklich raus
und das gab es dann auch in,
also diese Produkte hatten sie dann auch
in irgendeiner Wellness-Hotel,
ja,
Wellness-Abteilung, ja,
und die haben dann Leute dort getestet,
die vollkommen gesund waren
und da kamen,
die kamen dann raus,
so, keine Ahnung,
sie haben Aids oder sowas,
oder sie haben einen Gehirntumor.
Stell dir mal vor,
wie das dir deinen Urlaub versaut.
Stell dir vor,
du gehst ins Wellness-Hotel,
die sagen,
ja, wir können da so einen kleinen Test machen,
einfach nur einmal einen Finger pieksen,
ja, du liegst dann da,
irgendwie im Whirlpool
und auf einmal kriegst du ein Ergebnis,
ah, sie haben,
by the way,
sie haben einen Gehirntumor,
sie sollten mal zum Arzt gehen.
Das war,
das kam nicht so gut an.
Drücken wir es mal so aus,
das kam nicht so gut an
und das hat ja auch nicht gestimmt.
Also, das war ja,
war ja nicht
und dann kam halt später raus,
okay, dieses Ding hat einfach,
ja, nicht wirklich random,
aber es hat nicht zuverlässig funktioniert.
Das war eines der größten Scamsachen
der letzten Jahre in dieser Richtung
und ich weiß nicht,
ob die Alte nicht mittlerweile sogar im Knast ist.
Also, sie wurde auf jeden Fall verurteilt.
Ich weiß nicht,
was da jetzt rausgekommen ist,
genau am Ende.
Zumindest war da richtig,
richtig hart gescampt.
Richtig heftig gescampt wurde da.
Keine Ahnung.
So genau weiß ich das auch nicht mehr.
Ich weiß nur,
dass es eines der größten Scamsachen
der letzten Jahre so war.
Ist das so?
Okay,
x86 hat ein Problem.
Zehn ARM Laptops im Test.
Guck mal hier,
das sind die Messergebnisse.
Das Ding ist halt,
ich glaube,
dass,
wenn du Windows drauf installieren willst,
Windows unter ARM
ist wahrscheinlich nicht so gut.
Das ist wahrscheinlich nicht so gut.
Das ist vielleicht nicht so geil.
Wenn man darauf,
sagen wir mal,
Linux verwenden will,
dann ist es vielleicht gar nicht so schlecht.
Ach, das sind die Copilot-Notebooks.
Ja, nee.
Die würden wir eh nicht,
zumindest nicht mit der Standardsoftware ins Haus kommen.
Von zehn Copilot-Plus-Notebooks,
die wir ausführlich getestet haben.
Und ja,
da kann man wirklich von einer Erschütterung der Macht sprechen.
Die Teile sind nämlich nicht nur ein bisschen effizienter
als die meisten bisherigen Windows-Notebooks,
sondern die sind viel effizienter.
Guck mal.
Okay.
Hier oben sind die Copilot-Plus-Geräte,
hier unten die Mitbewerber.
Ja, und blenden wir hier unten mal die MacBooks aus
und konzentrieren uns auf die Laufzeit bei Last.
Ja, da halten alle Copilot-Plus-Notebooks
mindestens drei Stunden durch.
Und das ist auch wirklich Last.
Das ist nämlich der Benchmark 3D-Mark.
Also ganz ehrlich,
unter Load drei, vier Stunden ist ordentlich.
... in Dauerschleife.
Ja, und die Konkurrenz mit Intel oder AMD-CPU,
die schafft nur zwischen 1,2 und 2,6 Stunden.
Und das krasse daran, die Leistung, hier z.B. der Cinebench-Bänder...
Was? Kennst du dich eigentlich auch mit Fernseher aus
und hilfst mir ganz unheimlich...
Nicht wirklich.
Also kommt drauf an.
Ich habe keine spezifische Ahnung von Fernsehern.
... ist meist mindestens genauso gut,
oft sogar besser als die AMD- und Intel-Geräte.
In diesem Video stelle ich euch...
Aber du kannst den Chat fragen.
Der Chat ist immer äußerst high IQ, was sowas angeht.
... den Notebooks etwas genauer vor
und erkläre, ob es in der Praxis vielleicht noch...
Nachteile gibt.
Denn schließlich setzen die Co-Pilot-Plus-Geräte
auf eine ganz andere Prozessor-Architektur
als bisherige Windows-Geräte,
nämlich ARM statt x86.
Außerdem beantworte ich noch ein paar Fragen
zu den Notebooks, die ihr uns bei unserem ersten Video
zum Thema gestellt habt.
Bleibt dran.
Oh, liebe Hacker in die Internet-Surfer.
Herzlich willkommen hier.
Ah, die Zitrus immer.
Ganz ehrlich?
So sehr, wie Intel es verkackt hat
mit der 13. und 14. CPU-Generation?
Ja, man kann doch einfach sagen, dass...
... man kann einfach AMD kaufen.
Aber ich hätte auch keine Probleme,
was komplett anderes auszuprobieren.
Wird es allerdings für mich nicht werden,
weil gerade im Hinblick auf
das, was ich mache, Desktop-Dings
und Gaming...
Ich glaube nicht, dass ein ARM-Desktop
in nächster Zeit da
die Möglichkeiten bieten wird.
Läuft da gut Linux drauf?
Meine Vermutung ist ja.
Das sollte zum größten Teil gut laufen.
Ich wollte übrigens gestern lustig sein
auf X,
ehemals Twitter.
Ich bin gestern an der CPU-Fabrik vorbei,
wo Intel meine CPU gebaut hat.
Und jetzt mal
unabhängig davon,
dass es ein cringe, unlustiges Bild ist
mit dem Text dabei.
Ich hoffe ernsthaft, dass Gigabyte
es mal auf die Reihe bekommt,
ein BIOS-Update rauszuhauen.
ASRock hat BIOS-Updates raus.
MSI hat BIOS-Updates raus.
Gigabyte hat auch
keine BIOS-Updates raus.
Nö.
Für mein Mainboard nicht.
Ich hab gestern geguckt.
GIGA... Gucken wir heute nochmal.
Gigabyte Z...
Ja, da ist doch.
Eros Elite.
Gucken wir mal.
Vielleicht ist es ja mittlerweile so.
Gestern war das noch nicht so.
1.0.
Oh, was ist mit der Seite los, Mann?
What the fuck, Alter?
Support? BIOS?
Ach ja.
Ja, dann ist das anscheinend doch...
Hab ich gestern bei der 1.1. Dings-Version geguckt, oder?
Ich hab gestern auf dem Klo gesessen
und hab das auf dem Tablet...
Ja, da hab ich Gigabyte unnötig gehatet.
Das stimmt.
Ich hab gestern auf dem Klo gesessen
und auf dem Tablet mein Notebook...
mein Mainboard, WTF, gesucht.
Und da war das noch irgendwie
vom Juni oder so, das Update.
Okay.
Ja, dann würde ich mal sagen,
mach ich mal ein BIOS-Update.
Ich hab noch ein ganz altes BIOS.
Ich hoffe, in der Zwischenzeit ist nix passiert,
was irgendwie...
dass die richtigen Rechte nicht mehr booten
oder so.
Meint ihr dieses Micro-Code-Update?
Wird das auch über Windows
verteilt?
Nee, oder?
Also, es müsste aber eigentlich gehen.
Ich weiß nicht, ob Windows das verteilt.
Ah, keine Ahnung.
Muss ich mir nachher mal angucken.
Ich mach mal ein BIOS-Update.
Weil ich hab echt keinen Bock.
Was?
10% increase during idle?
What?
Warum sollte da überhaupt was
increasen an Temperatur,
wenn die Spannung geringer ist?
Ich guck mir doch mal die Sachen nachher an.
Ja, das muss ich mir nachher mal
in Ruhe anschauen.
Aber da hab ich Gigabyte gestern
umsonst gehatet damit.
Ja, die haben tatsächlich...
Da hab ich einfach nur nicht richtig geguckt.
Ich hab's selbst
noch nicht ausprobiert.
Ich hab mich angemeldet für den
Alpha-Test. Ich bin auch freigeschaltet in Steam
mittlerweile. Und ich bin selbst
am überlegen, ob ich spielen soll, weil
ich wollte es eigentlich ausprobieren.
Und...
Warte, ich kann das doch nochmal erzählen.
Ich bin selbst ein bisschen skeptisch, ob ich es ausprobieren soll.
Als erstes ein China-Chinesen-Game.
Keine Ahnung, was da alles mit auf den Rechner kommt.
Aber gehen wir mal von aus, wird über Steam vertrieben.
Die haben sich das angeguckt. Wird schon passen.
Ähm...
Ich hab dann zwei, drei Stunden Gameplay nebenbei angeguckt.
Und irgendwie fand ich's nicht so
dolle, weil es sieht auf den ersten
Blick zwar aus wie eine
Mischung aus Warzone
und Battlefield.
Also, ich find grafisch
ist es sehr Warzone, Call of Duty
orientiert, Gameplay-mäßig teilweise
ein bisschen Battlefield. Doch, du brauchst
das BIOS-Update.
Achso, nee, es geht nicht um die aktuelle
Geschichte, sondern allgemein.
Nee, allgemein würde ich nie ein BIOS-Update machen.
Ich würde nur ein BIOS-Update machen, wenn es wirklich was bringt.
In dem Fall kann halt meine CPU viel früher
kaputt gehen, deswegen werde ich ein BIOS-Update machen.
Ja, und was ich gestern an Gameplay
gesehen hab, hat mir persönlich nicht so gefallen,
weil es waren sehr viele
Bots dabei. Ich mag Multiplayer-Spiele
nicht, wo
Bots als echte Spieler
erscheinen. Und an sich war das
Gameplay sehr...
Das wirkte so mobile-mäßig
so. Alles groß und
langsam? Weiß nicht.
Und das Ding ist halt, nachdem das in China
ein Chinesen-Game ist,
wird es wahrscheinlich, wenn es rauskommt,
monetarisiert sein bis zum Umfallen.
Deswegen, ich weiß nicht, ob es sich lohnt, das auszuprobieren,
ehrlich gesagt. Was sagst du denn
dazu, falls du es schon ausprobiert hast?
Moin Michael, 50 Billionen.
So, was gucken wir uns denn als nächstes an?
Achso, nee, mit den armen Notebooks
wollten wir uns ja angucken.
Geil, liebe Internet-Surfer. Herzlich willkommen hier.
Ja, aber was nützen jetzt die
stolzen Copilot-Notebooks, wenn es
kein Internet gibt? Ja, mal ganz davon abgesehen,
Copilot ist halt eh so ein Ding,
also Copilot Plus vor allem,
das ist dieses Ding, was laufenden Screenshots von
deiner Installation macht und in die Cloud
hochlädt, den würde ich ja prinzipiell schon mal
nicht verwenden. Ja, da hilft
der Comcase der Thomas Grenn
AG, der Sprenger dieses Videos.
Der Comcase ist ein Notfall-
Kommunikationskoffer, mit dem man auch
unter schwierigen Bedingungen die
Internetversorgung aufrecht erhalten kann.
Das Ganze funktioniert so, dass der eingebaute
Industrial-Router das Mobilfunk-
Internet über 4G oder 5G
einfängt und über LAN oder
WLAN weitergibt. Im Vergleich
zu Consumer-Hardware bietet der
Comcase viele Vorteile. So kann man ihn
zum Beispiel in einem Temperaturbereich
von minus 20 bis plus 75
Grad einsetzen. Auch ziemlich
besonders, die Stromversorgung
des 6-Watt-Routers läuft über
gängige 80-Volt-Akkus. Rauter.
Hier in diesem Fall sind es Makita-Akkus,
aber es gibt auch Adapter für Bosch, Metabo...
Das finde ich nice.
Da kann ich meine
Akkuschrauber-Akkus für verwenden.
Nicht, dass ich so einen Koffer
bräuchte. Und so weiter.
Je nach Akkukapazität beträgt die Laufzeit
des Comcase bis zu 24 Stunden.
Vorteil des Akkubetriebs
ist, dass dadurch die jährliche
DGUV-Prüfung nicht nötig ist,
anders als bei Netzangriff. Das Ding sieht aus
wie selbstgebaut in der Garage.
Geb ich dir recht. Ja, geb ich dir recht.
Bei Smartphones kann man an den
Comcase externe Antennen
anschließen, einmal für mobil... Wer würde sowas überhaupt
kaufen? Also das erste, was mir einfällt,
sind irgendwelche Servicetechniker.
Ja, stell dir vor, du bist
Servicetechniker für, keine Ahnung,
Windkraftanlagen oder so.
Und du brauchst eine Internetverbindung, da gibt's keine.
Also quasi so wirklich, wenn
du jemand bist, der wirklich an Arsch der Welt
muss.
... und auch für WLAN.
So lässt sich also auch in netztechnisch
problematischen Umgebungen noch
was rausholen. Mehr Infos zum Comcase
findet ihr auf der Thomas-Krenn-Website.
Link ist in der Beschreibung oder
hier im QR-Code.
Werbung Ende.
Ja, wenn's gar nix gibt,
das stimmt. Aber nur weil dein
Notebook das nicht empfangen kann mit seinen Mini-Antennen,
ist das vielleicht mit dem Case möglich.
Das ist aber auch das einzige. Ansonsten wüsste ich
auch nicht, wozu man das braucht, ehrlich gesagt.
Ne, weil ich, wenn ich
mit meinem Notebook selbst dort ins Internet
komme, oder mit meinem
Handy einen Hotspot aufmachen kann, dann brauch ich das nicht.
Das einzige, wo ich mir das halt
vorstellen könnte, ist, wenn du wirklich
schwierige Bedingungen hast,
und wenn du halt ne gescheite Antenne
und gescheites Equipment hast, dass du
da ne Verbindung kriegst. Ansonsten wüsste
ich auch nicht, wozu man's braucht.
Letzten Monat sind ein ganzer
Haufen Notebooks rausgekommen,
die alle die neuen Snapdragon
X-Prozessoren von Qualcomm nutzen.
Wem das jetzt nix sagt, ihr habt Snapdragon
wahrscheinlich schon mal im Kontext von
Smartphones gehört. Und ja, genau,
das ist die gleiche Architektur,
nämlich ARM. Ja, und bis vor kurzem
konnte man das eigentlich so zusammenfassen.
Ja, Handys und Tablets nutzen ARM,
Computer nutzen x86.
Also x86, die
Mikroprozessor... Außer man ist Apple.
... die Intel vor 45 Jahren
erfunden hat. Kleines Infobröckchen
am Rande, der erste
Mikroprozessor, der in Serie
gefertigt wurde, war 1971
der Intel 4004.
4004? 3003?
Merkt ihr, ne?
Ja, ja, aber das ist nur eine der vielen
Inspirationen, die uns auf den Namen
dieses Channels hier gebracht haben.
Die anderen denk ich mir...
Die erzähle ich
euch ein andern Mal.
Also, jahrzehntelang lief
ein Computer primär mit x86.
Bis Apple dann ab Ende
2020 anfing, eigene
ARM-Chips in ihr Recht...
Und da musst du Apple ja mal echt zugutehalten.
Was Apple da an
Hardware baut, ist wirklich nice.
Also, stromverbrauchsmäßig
und performancemäßig ist das
nicht schlecht.
Apple Silicon haben die das genannt
und die Prozessoren, diesen M1, M2,
M3 und so weiter. Die flutschen.
Die flutschen richtig.
Die haben einen wichtigen Rums in der Notebook-Welt verursacht.
Denn die Leistung und
Akkulaufzeit waren im Vergleich
zu vielen x86-Windows-Notebooks
nicht nur besser, sondern
wirklich eine ganz andere Sportart.
Da hatten wir auch schon Videos dazu gemacht.
So, jetzt spulen wir mal 3,5 Jahre vor
und jetzt gibt es ARM auch in
Windows-Notebooks. Also, das gab es immer mal
wieder vorher schon, so nicht.
Windows läuft schon lange auf ARM,
aber das war nie wirklich
konkurrenzfähig. Jetzt ist
das aber schon konkurrenzfähig. Und wie.
Ihr habt ja wahrscheinlich schon unser erstes Video
zum Thema gesehen. Da hatten wir das Microsoft
Surface 7 15 Zoll getestet.
Da ging es ja viel um die,
sagen wir mal eher enttäuschenden
KI-Copilot-Funktionen in
Windows. Und deshalb klammere ich das
KI-Thema in diesem Video mal aus.
Microsoft versucht übrigens wirklich
an jeder Ecke irgendwas
mit AI zu verkaufen.
Letztens war auch so ein Termin mit Microsoft.
Da waren Google-Vertreter am Start,
Microsoft-Vertreter am Start.
Während Google halt wirklich
war, also es ging nicht drum,
dass irgendwie AI-Sachen oder so gekauft
werden soll, sondern es ging um ihre
Cloud-Angebote. Wohingegen Google
tatsächlich was zum Thema erzählt hat,
hat Microsoft im Prinzip
3 Stunden über AI
gelabert.
So ist ja eigentlich alles gesagt.
Also, wichtig ist nur, alle in diesem
Video hier vorgestellten Rechner haben
so eine sogenannte Neural Processing Unit,
also einen KI-Prozessor,
mit dem man diverses KI-Zeug
beschleunigen kann. Aber bislang gibt's
da halt wenig Sinnvolles. Mal sehen, wie das
in Zukunft wird. Wichtig ist aber
ja bei den Notebooks vor allem,
wie performen die Dinger heutzutage
schon im Alltag? Und da muss man einfach
sagen, machen die super. Vor allem
die Akkulaufzeiten, die sind einfach
richtig gut. Über 34 Stunden
bei ruhendem Desktop und
mit eingeschalteten Display bei 100
Candela pro Quadratmeter haben wir
zum Beispiel bei dem Lenovo Thinkpad
T14s Gen 6 gemessen. Das ist echt nicht schlecht.
Die Gen 4
Version des T14s
Thinkpads, die wir Ende 2023
getestet haben, mit AMD Ryzen
7 Pro 7840U,
die hat weniger als halb so
lange durchgehalten. Man sieht es
allerdings hier in der Benchmark-Tabelle der
Snapdragon X-Geräte. Das Thinkpad
erreicht im Cinebench Multicore
nur 601 Punkte,
die Konkurrenz mit dem gleichen Prozessor
kommt auf bis zu 950 Punkte.
Also zum Beispiel das Asus Vivobook
S15. Ja, aber der Grund dafür sind
einfach nur die unterschiedlichen Kühlphilosophien.
Also Lenovo will, dass
das Thinkpad im Standardmodus live...
Übrigens, die Optik, ich mag ja immer noch die Optik
von den... Mittlerweile
Lenovo, früher waren es IBM-Kisten,
mit diesem Nippel hier in der Mitte.
Das ist so eines
der Merkmale
eben von diesen Thinkpad-Geräten.
Die gibt es seit...
Seit 100 Jahren sehen die Dinger halt
gefühlt so aus. Und ich finde das
nice, dass sie das immer noch beibehalten
haben. Auch hier unten die Tasten am Touchpad
und so. ...bleibt, statt also den Lüfter
hochzudrehen, wird der Takt
einfach runtergedreht. Asus macht das halt
umgekehrt. Lüfter lauter, damit der
Prozessor nicht drosseln muss. Aber wie gesagt,
wir reden hier nur vom Standardmodus.
Man kann das in Windows einfach umstellen
und dann selbst entscheiden, ob man lieber
maximale Geschwindigkeit oder es
eben ruhiger haben will. Generell gilt
für alle Snapdragon X-CPUs, die
gefühlte Schwoptizität ist
super gut. Vor allem, wenn das
Notebooks sind, die ein 120-Hertz-Display
eingebaut haben. Das waren in unserem Testfeld
alle, bis auf... Mittlerweile sind wir aber auch
bei Notebooks bei 120-Hertz.
Das begrüße ich sehr. Auf
Lenovo Yoga Slim 7X
mit 90-Hertz-Display, HP Omnibook
X AI14
und dem Lenovo Thinkpad T13s
Gen 6. Die haben nur ein 60-Hertz-Display.
Es gibt aber ohnehin die meisten
Modelle auch mit unterschiedlichen
Bildschirmkonfigurationen. Ich persönlich
würde da auf jeden Fall mehr als 60-Hertz
empfehlen, weil sich das einfach geschmeidiger
anfühlt. Ich habe allerdings schon Leute gesehen, die
meinen, sie nehmen da keinen Unterschied wahr.
Also am besten ausprobieren. Ich persönlich
will nur noch so arbeiten.
Dass das Thinkpad so heftige
Akkulaufzeiten schafft, hat allerdings
vor allem mit diesem langsameren Display
zu tun. Das ist nämlich so ein Low-Power-
Panel, das halt ja Strom spart.
Es gibt das Gerät auch mit 120-Hertz-
OLED. OLEDs sehen meiner
Meinung nach viel schöner aus.
Das geht aber auch auf Kosten der Leistung.
Wenn man so ein OLED hat, dann sollte man auf jeden Fall
darauf achten, möglichst dunkle
Bildschirminhalte zu verwenden. Also Windows
immer im Dark-Mode betreiben. Weil OLEDs
haben eine höhere Leistungsaufnahme, wenn
sie weiß anzeigen, als wenn sie schwarz
anzeigen. Apropos OLED, so ein
OLED-Display haben 510 Testgeräte.
Gut, macht ja auch Sinn.
Bei den anderen ist die Hintergrundbeleuchtung immer
gleich so
an und wird dann entweder geblockt
oder nicht. Bei OLED
habe ich mir noch so nie drüber Gedanken
gemacht, aber
es ergibt Sinn.
Ja, und die Vorteile kennt ihr ja
wahrscheinlich. Also richtig farbstark,
nicht blinkwinkelabhängig und vor allem
ein super dunkles Schwarz. Allerdings sind
alle OLEDs im Test spiegelnd. Matte
Bildschirme hatten nur das ThinkPad
und der Dell XPS 13.
Achso ja, alle Displays haben das etwas
höhere, also das etwas
höhere 3 zu 2, beziehungsweise
16 zu 10 Format. Nur das
Asus Vivobook kommt mit
16 zu 9 Display. So, wo wir
hier schon bei Nummern sind,
Qualcomm hat sich da für die Prozessoren
so ein Typ-Bezeichnungs-Zahlen-
Chaos ausgedacht, dass ich
zumindest kurz einmal böse gucken muss.
Also, das
Top-Modell ist der Snapdragon
X-Elite X1E.
Leute, ich habe mir letztens eine Mikrowelle gekauft.
Die Bezeichnung von den Geräten ist wirklich auch
jenseits von allem. Wo ich denke so, wer
hat sich diese randomizede
Zahlenkolonne ausgedacht?
8400. Der X-Elite X1E
8100 ist bei den
Taktraten etwas abgespeckt.
Ja, und der X1E
7800 ist eigentlich genau wie der
80er, hat aber kein Single
Threading Boost. Ja, und last but not least
gibt es den Snapdragon X Plus,
also nicht Elite, X1P
6400. Der ist
wie der Elite 78er,
hat aber nur 10 statt 12
CPU-Kerne. Alle 4 haben die gleiche
NPU, also die ist gleich leistungsstark,
aber die GPU ist beim 100er
mit 4,6 Teraflops etwas
leistungsstärker als bei den anderen
deren GPU wird mit 3,8
Teraflops angegeben. So, und jetzt
nochmal kurz zur Leistung. Also die
sind alle wirklich schnell, also wirklich
schnell. Guck mal, also beim Cinebench
Multicore, da kratzt der XPS 13
an den 1000 Punkten. Sowas
gab es bislang einfach nicht bei so
kompakten Notebooks wie bei uns. 1000
Punkten. Ja, guck mal,
das ist leistungsmäßig ähnlich
gut wie die Ryzen CPUs.
Sowas gab es bislang einfach
nicht bei so kompakten Notebooks
wie bei uns im Tisch. Ja, ein Spiel kannst du vergessen,
muss man dann schon so ein fetteres Gaming
Notebook nehmen mit viel lauteren
Lüftern und viel höherer Leistungsaufnahme.
So, aber wir haben ja bislang nur von
der CPU-Leistung gesprochen, noch nicht von
der GPU-Leistung. Und da muss man
nicht lange um den heißen Brei herumreden.
Die GPU-Leistung ist
unterdurchschnittlich. Also zum Beispiel schaffen
die ja allesamt aktiv gekühlten
Snapdragon Notebooks sogar deutlich weniger
Plastikleistung als das passiv gekühlte
MacBook Air
mit M3 Prozessor.
Ja, und so spezielle Gaming Notebooks,
die spielen ja sowieso eine ganz andere Liga.
Gut, aber da ist die Akkulaufzeit
aber auch
ja, eine ganze
Ecke kürzer.
1,4 Stunden
oder was?
Und das ist meiner Meinung nach
immer noch gut für einen Gaming Notebook,
wenn sich was tut.
Also wenn es euch um Gaming geht, dann
solltet ihr zumindest um die erste
Snapdragon X Generation einen Bogen machen.
Ne, habe ich nicht.
Das heißt aber nicht, dass man gar nicht spielt.
Also gerade ältere Spiele laufen
oft echt okay. Also
Fallout 4 zum Beispiel konnte ich
Gucken wir uns gleich an.
Wie läuft denn der Kram? Gibt es das als native
ARM-Anwendung?
Oder ist das irgendeine
on the fly
assembly translation
Geschichte, dass das funktioniert?
Mit vollen Details
flüssig spielen. Aber leider ist oft
gar nicht die Geschwindigkeit das Problem, sondern
oft laufen die Spiele gar nicht.
Vor allem Titel, die so anti-cheat
beziehungsweise Kopierstoff-Software mitbringen.
Da gibt es oft Probleme, weil solche Software
ganz eng an der Hardware läuft
und ja, wenn die nicht angepasst ist
an ARM, dann klappt das einfach nicht.
Spiele, die gar nicht laufen, sind zum Beispiel
Fortnite, Valorant,
PUBG, Counter-Strike 2, Warframe,
Diablo 4 und Elden Ring.
Aber ich denke, das ist nur eine Frage
der Zeit. Und mal davon abgesehen, ich glaube auch nicht,
dass diese Spiele gut drauf laufen würden und
ich glaube auch nicht, dass Leute sich so ein Notebook kaufen,
das primär dafür
gekauft haben. Ist die anti-cheat
Software und diese Kopierschütz-Dinger an ARM
angepasst werden? Und dann sollten
die Sachen auch funktionieren.
Das liegt aber daran, mein Arbeits-Notebook
ist auch kacke, was das angeht.
Das liegt aber daran, dass das
Windows drauf hat und 24
Virenscanner und Geschiss-Security-Sachen
im Hintergrund laufen haben, die permanent
zig CPU-Leistungen verbrauchen. Ich glaube,
das ist bei dir auch so.
Weil ansonsten hält das schon länger als 2 Stunden
mit Teams und Browser.
Ok, Desktop-Sharing, das macht natürlich ein bisschen was aus.
Aber was da im Hintergrund alles für ein Schrott
läuft auf meinem Arbeits-Notebook ist nicht mal feierlich.
Frage von euch beantworten, die lautet
nämlich, gibt es für die Windows ARM
Computer einen x86 Emulator
wie bei Apple mit Rosetta?
Ja, genau so ist das. Da läuft ein
Emulator im Hintergrund, der sofort aktiv wird,
wenn man eine x86 Software
startet. Und diesen Emulator, da
merkt man gar nicht, dass er aktiv wird. Also das ist
jetzt nicht so, dass da dann erstmal starte
Emulator oder so steht, sondern das funktioniert einfach.
Ob da jetzt gerade x86
oder ARM Software läuft, das sieht man
übrigens nur im Task Manager, ansonsten...
Ich fand das gar nicht mit. Wie viel Prozent
Leistung der Emulator kostet, das
kann man leider nicht so pauschal sagen,
das ist sehr unterschiedlich, aber
zweistellig ist das in den meisten Fällen
schon. Es ist aber gar nicht so ein großes
Problem, weil die Dinger so schnell sind, dass
der Emulator-Verlust gar nicht
ins Gewicht fällt. Ja, und es fühlt sich dann trotz
Emulation oft schneller an, als
bei vielen x86 Notebooks.
Und apropos Emulation, ihr
hattet auch gefragt, ob da auch richtig altes
Software drauf läuft, und ja, also ich
habe da 20 Jahre alte exe-Dateien,
aufrufen können, problemlos, und
auch spezielle Software klappt. Wir haben zum Beispiel
die Banking-Anwendung StarMoney14
erfolgreich ausprobiert, sogar mit
Smart Card Reader. Für den,
also das war ein Cyberjack RFID,
gab es zwar keinen ARM-kompatiblen
Treiber per Windows-Update, aber auf
der Website vom Hersteller Rainer
SCT konnte man einen 100 haben. Rainer
SCT. Die Netzwerkdrucker und Scanner, die wir
ausprobiert haben, ja, die haben auch funktioniert,
die druckten und scannten alle. Was allerdings
nicht lief, die Google Drive App,
aber das ist wohl nur noch eine Frage.
Der Zeit. Genauso wie die ARM-Version von
Das Ding nicht funktioniert. Das würde ich
jetzt vermuten, ist eigentlich eine der simpelsten Sachen,
die da drauf laufen sollten. Und Adobe Premiere,
die ist ja auch schon angekündigt. Ja, und das Schnittprogramm
DaVinci Resolve funktioniert sogar schon seit
Version 19 explizit mit
den Snapdragon Xen. Euch hat da
auch noch interessiert, ob die Notebooks
aufrüstbar sind, also ob das wie
bei Apple alles hart verlötet ist,
oder ob man da... Ich persönlich gehe davon aus,
viel kann man da nicht machen. Vielleicht einen RAM-Riegel
tauschen, das war es aber auch.
Zumindest habe ich da eine halbgute
Nachricht für euch. Der Arbeitsspeicher
ist zwar überall aufgelötet, aber
die SSDs könnt ihr bei den meisten Geräten
austauschen. Guck mal, Microsoft
hat das sogar in einem... Das ist gut, weil Apple
gerade, gerade Apple lässt sich SSD-Speicher
so unsinnig teuer bezahlen.
Gibt es VMware für ARM?
Gute Frage, ich glaube nicht.
... ein Video erklärt, wie das geht. Also es gibt
Es gab mal eine Beta-Version von
ESX für Raspberry Pi, aber das
bringt uns ja nichts. Also VMware
für X6, für
ARM Windows, das
habe ich noch nicht... Also glaube ich nicht.
Nur bei den beiden Samsung Notebooks, da ist
der Flash-Speicher wie bei Apple aufgelötet.
Die lassen sich also nicht aufrüsten.
Ja, was viele von euch auch kommentiert haben,
dass sie gerne Linux installieren
würden, weil sie gerne ein effizientes
Linux-Notebook mit langer Akkulaufzeit
hätten und sie auch genervt sind von den
ganzen Windows-Sperenzchen, Stichwort
Recall und so. Ja, und da muss ich euch
zumindest jetzt noch enttäuschen. Der
aktuelle Linux-Körnel unterstützt zwar
explizit die Snapdragon
X-Prozessoren, aber bislang
funktioniert das alles mehr schlecht als recht
bzw. gar nicht. Ich habe bislang jedenfalls
noch kein Linux-Desktop zum
Laufen bekommen. Und wenn ich mir so Meldungen angucke,
dass da jetzt Linux-Patches rauskommen,
die die komplette GPU-Einheit der
Snapdragons deaktivieren, ja, das
hört sich für mich so an, als würde das nur
ziemlich lange dauern, bis das alles
smooth funktioniert.
Mein Fazit. Der Intel-Gründer
Andy Grove soll ja Anfang der 90er...
Jetzt wird erst einmal wieder diskutiert
bei den Desktops. Muss
der jeweilige Desktop das implementieren? Muss
das in den Mesa-Treibern
gemacht werden? Muss das im Körnel gemacht werden?
Muss das bei der Vulkan-Schnittstelle, bei der OpenGL-
Schnittstelle gemacht werden? Wo muss das und
wer ist dran schuld? Das dauert jetzt vorneweg
zwei Jahre, bis die sich einig sind, wer an welcher
Stelle was programmieren muss.
Und dann interessiert es die Leute schon nicht mehr.
... in einem Meeting mal so eine Zeichnung gemacht haben,
in der Mitte so eine Burg. Das sollte
Intels Profitabilität sein
und da drumrum so ein Burggraben,
der die Burg beschützen soll.
Das ist doch 100 pro auf irgendeinem super
agilen Meeting entstanden, oder? Das sollte
die x86-Architektur sein.
Ich sag jetzt mal so, ich wäre mir da
nicht so sicher, dass der Burggraben
noch so lange hält. Also die x86-
Fraktion reagiert da jetzt gerade natürlich
und arbeitet dran, das alles
effizienter zu machen. Es kommt jetzt auch bald
Zen 5 von AMD. Das könnte nochmal
aufregend werden. Aber mal gucken,
ob das in Sachen Effizienz den
Snapdragons wirklich Konkurrenz machen
kann. Sogar der durchaus sehr
kritische CT-Notebook-Experte
Florian Müßig hat sich in seinem Test
richtig aus dem Fenster gelehnt. Er meint,
nämlich, dass die neue Windows-on-Arm-Hardware
so attraktiv ist, dass sie
viel mehr Verbreitung finden wird als
bisherige ARM-Rechner und
Hard- und Softwareentwicklung.
Desktop-Virtualisierung unter Windows.
Auf jeden Fall nachziehen müssen. Das wird vielleicht
nicht so schnell passieren wie im Apple-Kosmos,
aber Windows-on-Arm lässt endlich
die Phase hinter sich, wo es weder
Henne noch Ei gab.
Das sehe ich ganz genau so. Achso, und wenn
ihr euch jetzt konkrete Geräteempfehlungen
der 10 Testkandidaten wünscht, da
muss ich euch leider enttäuschen, denn das ist auf
jeden Fall eine ziemliche Geschmackssache.
Also, will man lieber ein spiegelndes Display?
Will man lieber ein mattes? Findet man OLED wichtig?
Ist einem so ein leises Betriebsgeräusch
wichtig? Ist einem das egal? Man will
absolute Performance? Also, was ich auf jeden Fall
sagen kann, die beiden Samsung-Geräte
sind am leisesten von allen,
gehören aber auch zu den teuersten Modellen und
am preisgünstigsten kommt man zurzeit
mit dem Microsoft Surface Laptop 7
13,8 Zoll an
so einen Copilot Plus Notebook. Der kostet
1200 Euro. Für alle
anderen Geräte muss man mindestens 100 Euro
mehr bezahlen. Ja, und wenn euch das alles noch
zu teuer ist, dann könnt ihr noch bis Herbst warten,
kommen nämlich die günstigeren Snapdragon
X Ableger mit weniger Kern,
nämlich maximal...
Das habe ich mir in witziger Weise auch gerade überlegt,
warum nicht einfach was rausbringen, wobei das da ist.
Ich glaube, das Problem ist, du kannst es ja nicht
zu...
Ich glaube nicht, dass Windows in der
Lage ist,
sagen wir mal, von einer armen CPU,
dass eine arme Windows läuft,
laufen kann, und dass dann
x86 Software quasi auf die x86
CPU auslagert und umgedreht ist.
Ich glaube nicht, dass das möglich ist,
oder weiteres. Du müsstest dann quasi
komplett neu booten, du bräuchtest doppelt
so große CPUs,
die performancemäßig
auch nicht so weit auseinander liegen, also wo man sich dann
fragt, macht es überhaupt Sinn?
Das einzige, was halt wofür es Sinn
machen würde, ist, wenn du noch eine fettere GPU
drinne hast. Ich glaube, das ist so ein Spezialfall.
Ich glaube nicht, dass sich sowas
sich da durchsetzt,
kommen wird.
Es wird dann auch Geräte unter 1.000 Euro geben,
die werden dann auch deutlich
massenmarktauglicher. Was meint ihr, habt ihr
da Bock drauf? Interessieren euch die Teile überhaupt?
Ja, finde ich mega, die Entwicklung.
Finde ich super.
Ich habe schon jahrelang kein Notebook mehr, weil es einfach
kein gescheites Gerät gibt, was mich irgendwie anspricht.
Ich brauche es auch ehrlich gesagt nicht.
Aber
so eine Armkiste
mit knapp
zwei Tagen Laufzeit,
solange
sie zum größten Teil rumeidelt,
das ist was.
Das könnte ich mir vorstellen.
Ich glaube,
das ist tatsächlich deutlich
schwieriger, als man sich das Ganze so
vorstellt.
Ich sage nicht,
dass es nicht möglich wäre,
aber ich stelle es mir echt
kompliziert vor, dass du
einen Arm Windows laufen hast und dort
quasi Task Schedule kannst auf
eine x86 CPU.
Da sind wahrscheinlich in den Details die Sachen
zu unterschiedlich.
Bei dem einen sind
die Bytes absteigend,
beim anderen aufsteigend oder weiß ich nicht,
rate ich jetzt einfach mal.
Ich weiß nicht, wie es mit Parameterübergabe
bei Funktionen aussieht, ob das zwischen
beiden CPUs, also keine Ahnung.
Das stelle ich mir
schwierig vor,
dass du quasi so einen x86
Co-Prozessor hast für alles, was
fette x86 Performance braucht.
Also
weiß ich nicht, das stelle
ich mir irgendwie nicht so...
Es gibt
noch viele
andere
всяf
Funktionen.
Ich finde es
wirklich
einfach
easy machbar vor.
Welche VM unter Linux findest du am besten?
Kommt drauf an, was du machen willst.
Also für reine Desktop-Virtualisierung
ist vor allem
Workstation und Virtualbox
Ja, aber für reine Desktop-Virtualisierung,
wo du halt auch ein bisschen halbwegs
schnelle Grafikausgabe haben willst,
ja, also KVM
ist auch gut. Mit KVM musst du halt
ein bisschen basteln. Ja, mit KVM kannst du beispielsweise
eine Grafikkarte durchreichen
und dann mit Looking Glass die Ausgabe
auf dein Host
kopieren, dass es sich dann ein bisschen so verhält
wie vor allem bei Workstation, aber ein bisschen bessere
Performance hat. Da gibt es vieles.
Wenn ich einfach problemlose
Desktop-Virtualisierung haben möchte,
halt mit grafischer
Oberfläche und sowas, dann würde ich
wahrscheinlich auch unter Linux vor allem bei Workstation
oder VirtualBox verwenden.
Wobei man mit KVM da deutlich
mehr Spielereien machen kann,
mehr Möglichkeiten hat.
So gut. Das ist ja das
Schöne heutzutage, es gibt ja mehrere Anwendungsgebiete.
Es gibt auch Leute, die kommen
komplett ohne Computer aus und haben nur noch
ein Smartphone und ein Tablet.
Das könnte ich mir nicht vorstellen.
Ich benutze Tablets, mehrere
Tablets, mehrere Smartphones am Stadion,
Desktop-PCs.
Aber ich bin eh nicht normal, was das angeht.
Ich bin eh da viel zu
technisiert
im Vergleich zu
den Normalsterblichen, jetzt meine ich.
Ich meine, allein schon, dass ich ein dediziertes
Klo-Tablet habe, ist nicht normal
vermutlich. Habt ihr auch
ein Tablet, was nur dafür da ist, auf dem Klo zu
liegen und
zum Lesen auf dem Klo benutzt?
Benutzt es für nichts anderes.
Das liegt auf dem Klo. Also für mich gar nicht.
Manchmal nehme ich das mit und gucke noch irgendeinen Film
im Bett oder so, aber
das liegt zu 99% auf dem Klo und dient
dazu, dass ich im Klo in Ruhe lesen kann.
Hallo zusammen, kann mir jemand
einen 2,5 Gigabit Managed Switch
mit mindestens 4,5...
Ich kann dir einen ganz guten Switch
empfehlen, auch von Mikrotik, aber
Möchtest du Kupfer-Ports?
Wahrscheinlich, gell?
Ach so, ah, nee, du willst
8 Ports insgesamt. Ja, nee,
da fällt mir aus dem Kopf auch grad keiner ein.
Du willst wahrscheinlich
4 Kupfer,
Ports, RJ45,
2,5 und 4 Weide.
Ja, du musst einfach... Also Mikrotik
hat 100 pro irgendwas.
Ob's passiv gekühlt ist, gute Frage,
aber die haben ja eine gute Übersicht.
Aber es fällt mir keiner aus dem Kopf
ein. Also ich hab hier einen...
Ich hab hier einen...
Moment, was hab ich hier hinten stehen?
CSS
610?
Aber
der hat nur...
2...
2 SFP-Plus-Ports
und 8 1-Gig-Ports.
Das ist nicht das, was du haben willst.
Nee, hab ich zumindest keinen Tipp.
Ich müsste jetzt auch auf der Mikrotik-Webseite
durchgucken, das Ganze.
By the way, was ist das?
Das hat irgendjemand gepostet als
Raspberry-Pi-Alternative.
Ach so, das ist...
Äh, das ist ein Nook
mit
einem Raspberry-Pi-Pico innen drinnen, oder was soll das sein?
Ach nee, das ist ein ganz normaler.
Das ist ein...
Moment, das ist ein Nook, oder so.
Das ist quasi eine...
So ein Intel Atom oder sowas in der Richtung.
Plus ein Raspberry-Pi
in einem.
Und die kann man beide auch unabhängig
voneinander laufen lassen, oder...
Oder wie?
Ach, der macht nur I.O.
Ja, also, das Ding ist halt,
warum ich persönlich von sowas
Abstand halten würde,
weil da drauf wahrscheinlich kein...
äh, Debian läuft,
oder zumindest kein Debian,
wo du
die 1 zu 1 Raspberry-Pi-Sachen
Drop-In-mäßig
benutzen kannst.
Weil das Gute am Raspberry-Pi ist ja
eben das Ökosystem drumherum.
Das ist ein x86.
Jaja, das kommt ja noch dabei.
Also,
deswegen würde ich da wahrscheinlich
ein bisschen Abstand von halten, aus dem Grund.
Also, ein Raspberry-Pi-Ersatz
ist es auf jeden Fall nicht.
Es ist quasi
ein x86-Kiste
im Raspberry-Pi-Formfaktor,
der die Möglichkeit hat,
anscheinend hier
Raspberry-Pi-kompatible Header anzuschließen.
Das Ding ist viel besser
als ein Raspberry-Pi.
Wie kommst du drauf?
Das ist gar kein Raspberry-Pi-Ersatz.
Das Ding mag vielleicht schneller
als ein Raspberry-Pi sein.
Aber du kannst da drauf nicht so einfach,
sagen wir jetzt mal,
so was hier draufstecken.
Und es funktioniert.
Es geht einfach.
Auf meinen Raspberry-Pi
stöpsel ich das Ding drauf
und dann geht das.
Ich kann es da zwar draufstöpseln,
aber es geht da nicht.
Das ist ja gerade der Vorteil
vom Raspberry-Pi als Plattform,
dass es so viele kompatible Module gibt,
fertige Libraries und Tutorials.
Nur weil einer was baut,
was so groß ist wie ein Raspberry-Pi
und eine schnellere CPU hat,
ist das keine nicht automatisch
eine gute Raspberry-Pi-Alternative.
Und da bin ich,
skeptisch,
ob das
Monka-S
ein sinnvoller Ersatz ist.
Guck mal hier!
Alter, schrei nicht so rum!
Das sind die Messegeber!
Monka-S
und Monka-W.
Ich bastle aber auch gerne.
Das heißt, ausprobieren würde ich es trotzdem.
Aber ich glaube nicht, dass es ein Raspberry-Pi-Ersatz ist.
In dem Sinn.
Wie gesagt, nur weil was die Größe von einem Raspberry-Pi hat
und so aussieht wie ein Raspberry-Pi,
aber kein Raspberry-Pi ist,
schwierig zu sagen.
Wollt ihr sonst noch?
Der Auer!
Okay, das müssen wir uns angucken.
Ich teste das Intel Micro Code Update.
Da bin ich mal gespannt, was da rauskommt.
Ja, das müssen wir uns angucken.
Der Acht-Auer am Start.
Hallo zusammen und herzlich willkommen zurück zu einem weiteren Video.
Eigentlich sollte es heute um Ryzen 9700X-Köpfen gehen.
Das haben sich jetzt aber in den letzten paar Tagen ein paar Dinge ergeben,
weshalb es in diesem Video um drei Themen gehen wird.
Auch Ryzen 9000-Köpfen.
Ich meine, er ist ja der Experte, was so CPU-Gebastel angeht.
Ich muss sagen, ich werde das nicht mehr machen.
Ich habe einmal eine CPU geköpft,
nämlich in 8700K.
Und da habe ich so geschwitzt bei, Leute.
Das Ding ging danach, ja.
Das läuft übrigens immer noch.
Das läuft jetzt hier in meinem zweiten Rechner,
den ich hier als Vorschau-Rechner verwende.
Also das ist quasi der sechs Jahre alte Rechner, den ich davor hatte.
Ich habe einmal eine CPU geköpft.
Also das hat mich bestimmt fünf Jahre Lebenszeit gekostet, der Stress.
Ich habe mir damals eine 8700K gekauft.
Und...
Mal gucken, ob es dazu Bilder gibt.
Ja, von Hand geköpft, genau.
Und zwar...
Ja, genau.
Du musst dann quasi mit diesem...
Ach, okay, der ist...
Der ist hart drauf.
Der köpft das Ganze mit einer Rasierklinge.
Das habe ich mir nicht getraut, das mit einer Rasierklinge zu köpfen, die CPU.
Also ganz ehrlich, Leute.
Da habe ich echt geschwitzt bei,
mit Sachen auf meiner CPU rumzukratzen.
Das war sehr stressig.
Weil ich hatte damals eine 8700K.
Das war einer der ersten in Deutschland,
die ausgeliefert wurden.
Ich habe das wirklich, das war ganz neu gekauft.
Und hätte ich den kaputt gemacht,
hätte ich bestimmt zwei Monate keine neue CPU bekommen.
Die waren super knapp damals.
Dann hätte ich einen neuen PC hier stehen gehabt und könnte nichts damit machen.
Bringt das viel von den Temperaturen.
Heute nicht mehr so.
Beim 8700K war das ein Sonderfall, weil wie du siehst, ist der Heatspreader per Wärmeleitpaste auf der CPU drauf.
Das ist normalerweise nicht der Fall.
Also nur mal so zur Erklärung, was ihr hier seht.
Das ist innen von der CPU.
Hier ist die CPU und das ist der Deckel von der CPU.
Das ist normalerweise nicht zum Aufmachen gedacht.
Ihr macht normalerweise Wärmeleitpaste oben auf den Deckel von der CPU drauf und dann den Lüfter.
Intel war damals ein bisschen knauserig und hat sich das gespart und hat quasi den Heatspreader und die CPU verbunden mit Wärmeleitpaste.
Normalerweise ist das fest verlötet und du kannst da überhaupt nichts köpfen.
Aber damals war das Problem, dass diese Verbindung dank der Wärmeleitpaste nicht optimal war.
Und die CPUs viel wärmer geworden sind, als es nötig gewesen wäre.
Und ich habe die damals geköpft, genauso wie der, aber halt mit einem extra Gerät.
Da habe ich es abgemacht.
Ja, da musstest du das sauber machen.
Dann kommt so eine Flüssigmetalllegierung drauf.
Die wird da ein bisschen verteilt.
Und dann kommt der Heatspreader wieder oben drauf und dann wird das Ganze verklebt.
Und da kommt jetzt Wärmeleitpaste oben drauf.
Und diese Flüssigmetall-Legierung, die leitet halt viel besser, als die Wärmeleitpaste, die Intel da reingestopft hat.
Da hat Intel halt einfach mal versucht, 3 Cent zu sparen pro High-End-CPU.
Und ja, das hat wirklich, ich weiß nicht, ob es 20 Grad ausgemacht hat, aber es hat schon echt viel ausgemacht damals.
Heutzutage würde ich es nicht unbedingt mehr, also heute ist es eher so ein super High-End-Move,
seine CPU zu köpfen. Damals war das auch eine High-End-CPU, ja, aber das war ein wirklich,
auch damals war das ein sehr sinnvoller Move, wo man richtig viel rausholen konnte.
Ja, und mittlerweile nicht mehr.
Damals konnte man, genau, damals hätte man auch das Blech weglassen können und den Kühler direkt auf die CPU machen.
Da muss man aber enorm aufpassen, weil sobald man den Lüfter ein bisschen falsch anzieht,
zerstört man seine CPU, wenn man ein bisschen ungleichmäßig anzieht,
weil man hat den Lüfter, man hat dann quasi die Unterseite von dem Kühler direkt auf der CPU,
ein bisschen ungleichmäßig angezogen, CPU kaputt.
Dazu gab es noch das Problem, dass bestimmte Flüssigmetall-Ligierungen
und die Unterseite des Kupfer-Kühlkörpers vom Lüfter,
dass das oftmals nicht gut miteinander funktioniert hat.
Das heißt, es war auch damals, wenn man nicht genau wusste, was man macht,
keine gute Idee, die CPU quasi, also direkte Lüfter auf die Innenseite der CPU zu kleben.
Also ich habe auch wieder den Heatspreader drauf gemacht und einfach gleichmäßig angezogen und gut ist.
Um mein Ergebnis, dann das Intel Microcode-Update und dann auch eine Geschichte, wo es um Intel Arbeitsspeicher geht.
Kommen wir erstmal zum Köpfen von Ryzen 9000.
Nicht, dass ich es machen will, aber wir gucken uns das trotzdem an.
In den letzten Tagen hat sich ein Bild im Internet verbreitet, da gab es zum Beispiel Artikel zu von Overclock 3D,
von PC Games Hardware, von Tom's Hardware und so weiter.
Da war ein Bild zu sehen von einem geköpften, entweder 9600X oder 9700X.
Und da sieht man, dass der IODEI von dieser CPU, also der größere Chip, beschädigt ist.
Und da gab es ganz wilde Spekulationen in vielen von diesen Artikeln, warum denn diese CPU beim Köpfen beschädigt wurde.
Unter anderem habe ich gelesen,
Vielleicht hat der Typ einfach nicht aufgepasst beim Köpfen.
Dass der Deleter nicht warm genug war oder dass zum Beispiel das Load sich geändert hat,
dass das Load jetzt härter ist als vorher.
Da habe ich mich erst mal gefragt, wo zur Hölle kommen solche Informationen her.
Dann habe ich erst mal recherchiert, woher kommt denn eigentlich dieses Bild.
Und das Bild kommt von einem, ich will jetzt nicht sagen YouTuber, aber auf der Plattform Bilibili,
was ja im Prinzip das chinesische YouTube ist, hat einer, der heißt Tony Yu,
der macht auch relativ viele Videos zum Thema Hardware.
Also der kennt sich eigentlich aus bei diesem Thema.
Der hat ein Video zu diesem Thema gemacht, wo er eben die CPU geköpft hat.
Also man sieht, wie er die CPU eben...
Ja, mit so einem Gerät, wie der das macht, so einem ähnlichen habe ich meinen damals auch geköpft.
Den Thermal Grizzly Delidder reinlegt, dann schiebt er einmal den Slider zur Seite,
holt die CPU aus dem Delidder raus und packt dann einen Wärmeleitpastenspachtel in die Seite
und hebelt den Heatspadder nach unten.
Wo ich mich frage, wie zur Hölle kommt man auf die Idee, sowas zu machen?
Weil in der Anleitung und auch in jedem Video, was wir bisher gezeigt haben,
ist ganz klar ersichtlich, dass man die CPU ja in den Delidder packt
und dann bewegt sich dieser Slider, beziehungsweise man muss den Slider so lange
hin und her bewegen, bis sich durch Materialermüdung von dem Indium Load
sich der Heatspadder von alleine löst.
Und man darf natürlich auf gar keinen Fall auf die Idee kommen, da runter zu hebeln,
weil, und das betrifft sowohl Intel als auch AMD CPUs, wenn ihr da nach oben hebelt,
dann reißt ihr immer den Chip mit runter.
Und da frage ich mich auch, also das eine ist natürlich Tony Yu,
okay, der war vielleicht einfach zu faul, die Anleitung zu lesen,
keine Ahnung, wie er auf die Idee gekommen ist, ist ja am Ende sein Problem,
weil es ja auch...
Auch seine CPU ist, die beschädigt wurde, vielleicht war es einfach nur durch die eigene Faulheit.
Ist mir persönlich dann erstmal egal.
Ich frage mich dann aber bei den ganzen Newsartikeln, wo kommen die Informationen her?
Wenn ich da lesen...
Newsartikel bei Technikseiten, würde ich sagen, ist wie Newsartikel bei Gamingseiten.
Einer denkt sich was aus und die anderen schreiben es dann ab.
Ich lese, dass der Delidder nicht warm genug war.
Seit wann muss man den Delidder erwärmen?
Man muss sich auch nicht.
Newswebsites, bitte gebt euch mal ein bisschen mehr Mühe bei der Recherche,
weil man braucht genau fünf Minuten.
Kurz mal nachzuvollziehen, wo denn die Quelle von dem Bild herkommt
und dann sieht man auch direkt, wie die CPU geköpft wurde und warum die beschädigt wurde.
Aber in fünf Minuten muss man fünf Artikel schreiben, das geht nicht.
Manchmal frage ich mich so ein bisschen, was mit der Recherche passiert ist,
weil ich kann euch sagen, das ist ein Ryzen 9000 hier.
Den habe ich vor fast zwei Monaten schon geköpft.
Ich habe dann da schon angefangen, DirectEye zu machen,
habe natürlich die ganzen Produkte von uns zur Kompatibilität getestet.
Den Delidder, den Heatspreader, den Wasserkühler.
Ansonsten hätten wir auch nicht am 31. Juli schon auf der Thermal Grizzly Homepage
ein Statement hingeschrieben, um zu zeigen, dass die Produkte zu Ryzen 9000 kompatibel sind.
Das habe ich logischerweise vorher getestet, sonst hätten wir das nicht freigegeben.
Also ein bisschen mehr Recherche hätte da nicht geschadet.
Und wenn ihr sowas köpfen wollt, es ist problemlos möglich.
Es hat sich da nichts geändert.
Am Load hat sich nichts geändert, an der CPU auch nicht großartig.
Minimale Änderungen gibt es, aber die sind nicht relevant für den Delidder.
Das funktioniert nach wie vor absolut problemlos.
Und die beschädigte CPU hat nichts mit dem Delidding-Prozess zu tun,
sondern war einfach nur, weil man da falsch herangegangen ist.
Dieses Video wird präsentiert vom Seasonic Prime TX 1600 Watt Premium-Netzteil.
Mit 94% Effizienz bei 50% Auslastung ist das Netzteil 80 plus Titanium und Cybernetics Titanium zertifiziert.
Ich verwende die Seasonic Prime seit Jahren selbst und auch bei...
Habe ich nicht auch noch ein Seasonic-Netzteil?
...haben mich die Netzteile noch nie enttäuscht.
Alle nötigen Schutzfunktionen wie OPP, OVP, OCP oder OTP sind vorhanden.
Und was ich einfach krass finde, ist, dass die Seasonic darauf 12 Jahre Garantie gibt.
Alleine das spricht aus meiner Sicht schon für die Qualität und das Vertrauen,
dass die Seasonic in die eigenen Produkte und Netzteile hat.
Mehr findet ihr im Link in der Beschreibung.
Zweites Thema ist das kürzlich erschienene Intel Microcode-Update in neuen BIOS-Versionen.
Ihr habt es mit Sicherheit jetzt ja mitbekommen, dass die Intel-CPUs einige Probleme mit Stabilität haben
und dann teilweise auch gestorben sind.
Und jetzt gibt es seit ein, zwei Tagen Beta-BIOSe, die eben das neue Microcode-Update beinhalten.
Das ist das 0.1.1.1.
Moment, ist das auch ein Beta-BIOS?
Ich will mir kein Beta-BIOS installieren.
Ist das ein Beta-BIOS? Nee, oder?
Würde ich jetzt nicht sagen. Ich sehe da nichts von.
Was ist ein Beta-BIOS?
...neuen Update.
Und da gab es auch einen Post von Intel und in dem wurde beschrieben,
dass es auch minimale Performance-Einbußen geben kann.
Das Ganze hat mich natürlich interessiert.
Um zu checken, gibt es denn wirklich Performance-Einbußen?
Ich habe jetzt natürlich nicht jedes Spiel getestet, das es gibt,
sondern die, die ich üblicherweise sonst auch teste.
Da habe ich jetzt keine Änderungen vorgenommen.
Getestet habe ich das Ganze auf dem Apex-N-Core.
Einmal mit dem BIOS 14.02, das ist ein BIOS aus dem Juli.
Und dann eben das ganz neue 15.03, das eben den neuen Microcode-Patch beinhaltet.
Und dann schauen wir uns jetzt mal die Ergebnisse davon an.
Ich habe im BIOS das Intel Extreme-Profil ausgewählt, was den Power-Limit-Vorgaben von Intel entspricht.
Es gibt auch noch das Asus OC-Profile, das man auswählen könnte.
Seht ihr hier im Cinebench A23, da gibt es minimale Leistungsunterschiede.
Aber ich habe mich eben entschieden, das offizielle Intel Extreme-Profil,
das quasi die Standardeinstellungen sind, zu wählen.
Im Cinebench sehe ich hier nicht wirklich einen Unterschied zwischen dem alten und dem neuen BIOS,
also zwischen 14.02 und 15.03.
In Valorant dagegen sehen wir einen kleinen Unterschied von etwa 2,5% bei den jungen FPS.
Die Leistung sinkt von 680 auf 663.
Auch in Counter-Strike 2 konnte ich so einen leichten Einfluss sehen.
Performance etwa 2% niedriger bei den 1% Low und auch bei den Durchschnitts-FPS.
In Cyberpunk ist die Leistung dafür im Prinzip identisch.
Der neue Microcode ist ungefähr 1 FPS schneller und es liegt einfach an der Messflache.
Auch in Assassin's Creed Mirage bei 1080p und maximalen Details habe ich bei mir keinen Unterschied feststellen können.
Und als letztes Remnant 2, auch hier keine signifikante Änderung in der Performance.
Wenn ihr euch die Folien genau angeschaut habt, dann konnte man auch sehen,
dass in dem Szenario mit dem neuen Microcode-Update die CPU im Schnitt ganz leicht weniger Leistung aufnimmt.
Also irgendwo zwischen 1 bis teilweise 5 Watt weniger und auch minimal weniger Leistung gebracht hat.
Also irgendwo zwischen 0 und 3% weniger.
Und ich denke, da wird es bestimmt das eine oder andere Spiel geben, wo es vielleicht auch mal mehr ist.
Vielleicht auch eine andere Wendung, wo es mehr sein kann.
Aber ich würde jetzt mal sagen, so grundsätzlich gibt es da keinen großen Performance-Unterschied, der zu erwarten ist.
Also es stimmt mit dem überein.
Was Intel erstmal gesagt hat.
Ich würde aber natürlich noch weitere Tests von anderen abwarten, die dann wie gesagt wahrscheinlich noch andere Szenarien testen werden.
Grundsätzlich würde ich aber sagen, das ist auf jeden Fall eine Situation, wo ihr dringend updaten solltet.
Auch jetzt, wo es kein Beta-BIOS ist, würde ich persönlich das Update schon vollziehen.
Ist das wirklich ein Beta-BIOS? Ich sehe das so, bei mir sieht das für ein ganz normales BIOS aus.
Das weiter verfolgen und schauen, ob dann in den nächsten Tagen irgendwann ein offizielles Release-BIOS kommt.
Das dann flashen und dann hat man hoffentlich für die nächste Zeit,
erstmal Ruhe.
In meinem letzten Video habe ich das auch im Prinzip beendet mit, ich muss erstmal warten, wie Intel die ganze Thematik jetzt angeht und damit umgeht.
Zumindest mal hat Intel jetzt die Garantie offiziell weltweit von den ganzen 13. und 14. Generationen CPUs, die betroffen sein könnten, von 2 auf 5 Jahre angehoben.
Das ist schon mal echt ein guter Schritt, ein gutes Signal.
Und ich denke, das sollte auch einige Sorgen besänftigen, die ich auch gelesen habe.
Also wenn ihr jetzt Sorgen habt, dass eure CPU schon vorgeschädigt ist und dann vielleicht in 2 Jahren die Grätsche macht,
dann habt ihr auf jeden Fall noch Garantie und solltet...
Ja, es ist aber halt trotzdem Abfuck, ja?
Dann kackt dir der Rechner ab in 2 Jahren, den brauchst du dann gerade, dann musst du an Intel schreiben, Intel schickt dir das Ding irgendwie.
Ganz ehrlich, ich sag euch mal, wie es ist, ich würde mir wahrscheinlich, wenn mir das in 2 Jahren passiert, würde ich mir einfach einen neuen Rechner kaufen.
Anstatt da eine Woche oder zwei mit Intel rumzumachen, bis ich ein bisschen replacement CPU hab.
Das wissen die auch.
Problemlos.
Hoffentlich.
Die CPU getestet.
Die CPU getauscht bekommen.
Könnte man, könnte man jetzt da hinschreiben und sagen, ich habe eine betroffene CPU, ich hätte gerne eine neue, die schicken das los und ich kann die mir einbauen und die alten dann zurückschicken oder whatever.
Das würde ich sagen, okay, das würde ich mir überlegen, aber so, pfff, das wissen die auch, das ist für den Arsch, ja?
Ich hoffe, dass das ganze Debakel mit der 13. und 14. Generation damit auch ein Ende hat, dass wir die Zeit zeigen.
Man muss natürlich sagen, am Ende ärgerlich ist es.
Dass es ja mehrere Schritte gab, mehrere Updates in der Vergangenheit, auch mit Powerlimits und so weiter, dass man, wenn man zum Beispiel 14.900k beim Release gekauft hat, jetzt auf jeden Fall nicht mehr die Performance hat, wie wir Reviewer das zum Beispiel damals gezeigt haben.
Das ist auf jeden Fall ärgerlich und ich hoffe, dass es nicht mehr dazu kommt.
Das dritte und letzte Thema für heute betrifft auch wieder Intel.
Wisst ihr, wisst ihr, ich muss da echt mal sagen, ich bin echt enttäuscht, was die Hardwarequalität angeht.
Der aktuellen, so.
Desktop-Rechner-Generation.
Weil ich mein, ich hatte, wenn man sich das mal überlegt, das habe ich glaube ich letztes Mal schon gesagt.
Hallo Leute, hier ist der Max.
Wenn man sich das mal anguckt.
Von den Kisten, äh, von den Sachen, die in meiner Kiste drinnen sind.
Okay, nee, ich habe ein Be Quiet-Netzteil, also.
Die Samsung-SSD war verbuggt.
Hat einen Firmware-Update gebraucht.
Hat, äh, ist viel schneller.
Gealtert und ging viel schneller kaputt.
Also musste man Firmware updaten.
Die Intel-CPU kam jetzt zwei Jahre später raus, ist auch kaputt.
Muss auch geupdatet werden.
Ist vielleicht irreparabel kaputt.
Äh, der RAM wurde verkauft als 6400 mit diesen Settings.
Wenn ich so mit diesen Timings und diesem Takt betreibe, ist es nicht stabil.
Ähm, die Grafikkarte hatte diesen komischen Adapter von Nvidia dabei.
Und dafür berühmt war, dass es angefangen hat zu kokeln im Rechner.
Wo man sich denkt, wie kann das eigentlich sein.
Dass die Hälfte von meinem Rechner im Arsch ist.
Das Ding hat 5000 Euro gekostet, Mann.
Das ist nicht irgendwelche Drecks-Hardware.
Aber Zotac kann dafür nichts.
Das war der offizielle Nvidia-Adapter.
Die Grafikkarte ist top, kannst du nicht sagen.
Was ist das?
Was ist das? Ernsthaft?
Wie scheiße?
Wie kacke kann das sein?
Arbeitsspeichertakt.
Ich wurde am Donnerstag auf meinem Discord-Server darauf hingewiesen.
Wenn der Bauer sogar sagt, man hat kaum Performance-Einträge.
Wir skippen da mal kurz drüber.
Dann glaube ich dem das.
Dann werde ich nachher mal ein BIOS-Update machen.
Okay, ohne welche Terminal-Applications kann er nicht leben?
Wir skippen das jetzt einfach.
Age habe ich noch nie gehört.
Age? SSHS kenne ich auch nicht.
Kenne ich auch nicht.
Termshark klingt nach einer Wireshark-Sache fürs Terminal.
Okay.
Wir lernen anscheinend neue Terminal-Programme kennen,
die ich selbst noch nicht kenne.
Also wir sind mal gespannt.
Alter, die Porn-Musik im Hintergrund.
Was soll das sein?
Ah!
Sowas wie GPG, nur neu.
Okay, okay, skip.
SSHS.
Braucht man das?
Hast du Katzen? Nee, gerade nicht.
Nee, das brauche ich nicht.
Okay, nee, das brauche ich wirklich nicht.
Ich habe ein Skript,
das ruft, also auf der Arbeit,
hier daheim ist es ähnlich.
Hier daheim habe ich ja nicht 3000 Rechner.
Auf der Arbeit mache ich das so,
ich rufe einmal am Tag,
immer wenn ich mich morgens einlogge,
rufe ich einmal von unserem Ansible-Server
das Inventory ab
und generiere mir eine Liste daraus,
die ich dann nach FZF pipen kann
für SSH-Verbindungen.
Da habe ich immer topaktuelle Hostlisten bei mir,
die ich fuzzy searchen kann.
Okay, brauchen wir nicht.
Die Grafikkarten konnten nicht abfackeln,
die das Kabel
des Verbindungs... Moment,
das ist gerade hier.
Nvidia Cable 4090 Fire.
Suchen wir mal danach.
Hier.
Dieses Adapterkabel
hatte, sagen wir mal, den Hang dazu,
dass man es nicht richtig
reinsteckt.
Da musste man wirklich gucken,
dass es richtig fest und richtig bündig ist.
Das konnte man zu locker reinstecken
und dann hatte es schon Kontakt
und hatte zu viel Widerstand
und hat angefangen zu fackeln.
Das konnte damals passieren.
Die Grafikkarte selbst konnte nicht abfackeln
und mittlerweile haben die Netzteile
auch die passenden Stecker dafür.
Du brauchst diesen Adapterstecker nicht mehr.
...
Das brauche ich ganz bestimmt nicht.
So, was haben sie?
...
Ah, das ist quasi
Postman als Terminal
Anwendung.
Das ist gar nicht so schlecht.
Ich meine, ich bin immer noch
Curl-Enjoyer.
...
Das ist cool.
Kennt das jemand von euch?
Das gefällt mir, das bin ich mal geneigt
dazu sogar auszuprobieren.
Wie gesagt, ich bin Curl-Enjoyer,
ich werde wahrscheinlich noch nicht einmal
ein Terminal User Interface werden.
Aber für ein bisschen umfangreichere Sachen
kann das so schlecht sein.
...
Ja, Business-Analysten verwenden auch keine
Terminal Command Line Tools.
...
The go-to for most users is Wireshark.
Wireshark comes with a built-in CLI named T-Shark.
But T-Shark is quite raw.
So today we're looking at Terramshark, a tool wrapping over T-Shark.
It's written in Go, with almost 9000 stars on GitHub.
Terramshark is super convenient when you want to sniff packets and get to the bottom of things.
Das ist cool.
Just for reference, this is what T-Shark looks like out of the box.
Okay, das ist nice. Das ist wirklich nice. Das gefällt mir.
Dumping things into a file that's going to be inspected later.
But for a more involved approach, I'm adding Terramshark to my flake.
And when it's called, you can see this.
Ja, das gefällt mir.
A stream of packets with their information below, next to a hexadecimal representation.
Weiß ich nicht, ob die das eingeführt haben.
Scroll through the information below.
Das gefällt mir. Das ist im Endeffekt, das ist wirklich Wireshark im Terminal.
Das finde ich sehr gut. Das gefällt mir. Das gefällt mir ausgesprochen gut.
Das muss ich mal ausprobieren bei Gelegenheit.
The question mark pops the menu, where you can find different options like
backslash for zooming in and out, pipe to change the layout and toggle through it,
tab to move around paint, a file transfer utility between computers,
built with Charm Bracelet, which is always easy on the eye.
Oh mein Gott. Aber das ist nice.
Oh nee, jetzt schreien die Räume.
Ich habe gedacht, es gibt ein bisschen Cat-Content.
Möchte ich jetzt ein Wireshark-Tutorial?
Wireshark?
Ich habe noch eigentlich nur den Capture-Knopf drücken können und Follow-TCP-Stream machen.
Das reicht in der Regel.
Oh Leute, ich habe Hunger.
Das OSI-Modell.
Wie war das nochmal, Leute?
Please do not throw salami pizza away.
Oder wie?
Was war euer Merksatz?
Für das OSI-Modell?
Habt ihr da auch einen gehabt?
Ich glaube, please do not throw salami pizza away war mein Merksatz.
Das heißt, P...
Please.
Äh, P ist der erste OSI-Modell-Schicht.
Das heißt, P ist Physical.
D ist...
Ich habe keine Ahnung mehr, was OSI-Schicht-Modell 2 ist.
D...
Chat, was ist OSI-Modell-Schicht 2?
Ah ja, Dings, ähm...
Das ist Ethernet-Frames und sowas.
Aber wie heißt denn das?
Wie heißt OSI-Modell-Schicht 2?
Es muss mit...
D anfangen.
Please do do not.
Nächste ist N.
Nächste ist Network.
Nächste...
Data-Link.
Ja.
Okay, dann passt.
Nächste ist Network.
Das ist sowas wie, ähm...
Halt...
IP.
Oder IPX oder...
Oder so Zeug, ja.
IP.
Pakete.
Please do not throw.
T ist Transport.
Also, äh...
TCP, UDP...
Wer fällt mir da grad nicht ein?
Ähm...
TLS.
Auch auf der Ebene.
Stimmt noch ein paar obskure Dinger.
So, das nächste ist...
Please do not throw...
S...
Was ist Schicht...
Wo sind wir jetzt?
Schicht 5, ne?
Äh...
Sitzungsschicht ist das, glaube ich.
Session.
Schicht 5.
Da hab ich aber gar keine Ahnung, was es da für ein Beispiel für gibt.
Chat, habt ihr denn ein gutes Beispiel für...
OSI-Modell Schicht 5?
Ich glaub, das ist auch so ein Ding, das ist alles heutzutage verschwamm...
Verschwommen.
So.
Danach...
Sitzungsschicht.
Ja, das halten sie auf Deutsch.
Aber das ist doch keine Sitzungsschicht.
Ähm...
Pizza...
P...
Presentation...
Ist es, glaube ich.
Und 7 ist Application.
Das weiß ich aus dem Kopf.
Aber ich kann euch beim besten Willen keine gescheiten Beispiele für Session, Presentation und Application...
Ich meine für Application schon, aber ich kann euch da keine gescheiten Beispiele für sagen.
Wenn ich ehrlich bin.
Ich glaube 5, 6, 7 ist heutzutage sehr schwammig.
Interessiert ehrlich gesagt auch keinen.
Im OSI...
Also ganz ehrlich, dich interessiert eigentlich nur die Netzwerkgeschichte und das ist 1 bis 4.
Zumindest ist 7 Application.
Deswegen sagen ja manche...
Layer 8 Probleme.
Layer 8 gibt es offiziell nicht.
Aber Layer 8 ist halt der Typ, der vorm Computer sitzt.
Und das meiste sind Layer 8 Probleme.
Mit der Xbox.
Session sowas wie angemeldeter User.
Ich glaube nicht, dass es in Form...
In Form...
Beim OSI-Modell damit gemeint ist.
Weil angemeldeter User wäre ja im Prinzip noch über Application eigentlich.
Das ist ja quasi was in einer Application.
Und mit Application ist ja im OSI-Modell auch...
Letztendlich nicht wirklich eine Anwendung gemeint zwangsläufig.
Sondern...
Das logische Protokoll da oben drüber.
Also quasi HTTP oder sowas.
HTTP ist zum Beispiel eine Anwendung aus OSI-Schichtmodellen.
Also quasi das...
Die Logik, die da drüber läuft.
Also Schicht 7 ist dann nicht zwangsläufig der Browser.
Sondern eigentlich nur das HTTP-Master.
Es ist schwammig.
Letztendlich muss einen da eigentlich nur Schicht 1 bis 4 interessieren.
VPN eventuell.
VPN ist auch eine Anwendung aus OSI-Modell-Sicht, ja.
Also VPN wäre dann sowas wie IPsec.
Oder...
Wobei IPsec...
Auf was basiert IPsec?
Setzt das auf TCP auf oder ist das irgendein eigener Shit?
Also...
Ähm...
Ob ein VPN baut auf TCP und UDP auf, das weiß ich.
Bei IPsec bin ich mir da nicht so sicher.
Also IPsec ist entweder Schicht 4 oder Anwendung.
Nee.
IPsec müsste...
Ein Layer auf der gleichen Sache wie TCP und UDP sein, würde ich sagen.
Weil es basiert ja auf IP.
Und dann irgendwie noch ein Encryption-Layer.
Ich würde das auf der gleichen Ebene wie...
Wie TLS ansiedeln dann.
Also quasi hier auf Schicht 4.
Aber es ist alles ein bisschen schwammig.
Okay, es ist Schicht 3.
Was auch immer.
Ist auch egal.
Wir machen keine Physi-Ausbildung mehr.
Wir müssen das nicht mehr wissen.
Ich bin eh faul.
Ja, auch auf der Arbeit.
Letztens...
Wir hatten letztens mal wieder einen Azubi.
Da ging es auch um IP-Netze und sowas.
Da ging es auch um irgendwie 10...
Ähm...
Keine Ahnung.
10, 10 irgendwie Dings.
Bla...
Whatever.
Slash 22.
Da hab ich gesagt, weißt du was?
Nimm einfach IP-Kalk und guck nach...
Wo das Netz anfängt und wo das aufhört.
Okay, wo es anfängt ist ja immer relativ easy.
Aber...
Ja.
Wo es aufhört, keine Ahnung.
Solange es nicht in Slash 24 ist.
Slash 24 kann jeder noch erkennen, aber...
Ja.
Wenn man da mit so obskuren Sachen ankommt,
wie Slash 17 und sowas.
Dann ist es ja auch so, what?
Okay, Leute.
Wisst ihr, was ich jetzt mache?
Massive-Pipo-Fat-Time mache ich jetzt.
Heute gibt es...
Der Chat hat übrigens recht.
Heute gibt es Spaghetti-Bolognese.
Was?
Du hast eine Nachricht?
Geschrieben, die ich nicht gesehen habe.
Du hast eine neue CPU gekauft.
8000...
Du hast quasi von einer älteren Ryzen
auf eine neueren Ryzen geupgradet.
Ja, da hat sich sicherlich einiges getan
inzwischen.
100% ist natürlich extrem krass.
Das hätte ich jetzt nicht gedacht.
Aber es ist Valorant.
Valorant, ja, hätte ich jetzt gar nicht gedacht,
dass das so CPU-lastig ist.
Auf der anderen Seite, so Grafikkarten-mäßig,
das sieht ja schon ziemlich reudig aus teilweise.
Nope.
Habe ich noch nicht.
Aber die ist eh zum größten Teil idle.
Ich sage nichts, weil wenn ich sage,
mache ich es eh nicht, gefühlt, ja.
Okay, Leute, ich gehe jetzt was futtern.
Bis denn, macht's gut.
See you.